[Music]
the whole idea here for me is like let's
find people that that I want to learn
from people that inspire me and the
people like the exact people I would
want my kids to learn from and like I
literally cannot think of somebody
better than yourself um but uh I heard
what you said about your your dog man
and and um I'm really I'm I'm I'm I'm
really sorry about that and I I I know
if uh if if you want but do you want to
talk a little bit about that or you want
to talk about you know what your dog
meant to you and like cuz I like I've
had dogs my whole life man and and I
know with you you serve with this dog
and and uh so I got her while I was
active duty but I wasn't a dog handler
uh the whole story I was super depressed
I was going through this like
investigation at work and I went to Shot
Show you've heard that of course yeah
I've been there and so um there was
these dogs uh doing like a demonstration
there and my friendss were starting a
nonprofit but they went up to the dog uh
people they're like hey we need to get
we need to get Cody a dog we want to
make him our first recipient so a couple
weeks later I flew out to Wyoming and uh
found mun my dog and that's how I got
her so I bring her to work everywhere I
went and but I was a dog handler so like
it was like already taboo cuz no one had
an act Duty service dog but I did I said
I was desperate so she did everything
with me and then uh I had to stop
bringing her to work one day uh this
like new command guy came in he's like
they're like who is that guy why does he
have a dog like oh that's his service
dog uh his dog helps him out throughout
the day he's like well my wife helps me
out you don't see me bringing her around
like very conventional the people that
don't the people that people talk [__]
about in the military right because
they're just delusional yeah and um
delusional and conventional it's it's
it's sort of one and the same you feel
like people who are too steadfast in
their belief different militar you know
militar is like a lot of people stay in
because they're scared to get out a lot
of people St in because it's easy to be
a Power Trip and when you have that as
your identity you you can very just like
a character you can fall into it very
deeply and you know outside the box
thinking or doctrine is this I mean this
[__] was like written by like old white
guys like [__] you know 100 years ago
you know like 150 plus years ago like
things have changed you know we're
fighting we not with sticks and muskets
anymore we're things doing life
differently and there's a thing called a
human right we're not standing up on you
know uh uh battlefields looking at one
another and like taking turns to shoot
it right uh almost makes me think that
history is fake you know cuz just
thinking of it nowadays I'm like you're
that that's not even Brave that's just
that's ignorant you it's stupid yeah uh
but that's how we did things back in the
day and you know now we have the thing
called like people have feelings and
emotions and we're real we're asking
real people to do very unrealistic
things and uh you know I don't know I
was lucky I was in this part of Special
Operations community so we was able to
step into that role and I had a lot of
support but then I always have those
people that they just don't get it cuz
they live in they're Liv in another
reality so we call those people guest he
wasn't part of my special operations uh
outfit uh you've heard the sergeant
major sure so those those guys come into
our units from the Big Marine Corps uh
because to be a sergeant major you have
to be a thing called a first sergeant
which there's no team guy billets for
first sergeants and if you were to
become a first sergeant like if the
Marine Corps you're like hey you know
what Marine Corps I want to be a first
sergeant and then you get promoted as a
as a team guy you get sent to the Big
Marine Corps for like four years because
they want you to they wanted to spread
that leadership and that knowledge
experience to like a non infantry or
non-operational unit and then you can
come back as a potential sergeant major
but by that time unfortunately most of
those guys forget because now they're
thinking oh [__] I want to be the common
on the Marine Corps sergeant major so I
have to have this certain type of track
record and most people aren't willing to
put their put their their their dreams
for their self-promoting self-gratifying
you know existence on the line for you
know to change an environment right
Ingenuity and creativity and how how
like because it's not the norm right
right right right right and you and you
really found that I know when you went
overseas the first time you just saw
that it was just like it was a war being
fought in a way I mean just down to the
equipment that you guys had right I mean
it was just like you were we we were not
prepared for that yeah especially my
first deployment uh you know they gave
us like we didn't have
tourniquets and we had this thing called
quick clot before they had like the
combat gods that had the quick clot you
like poured into the wound and like
basically like coagulate the blood and
like it would like sear it and like stop
the bleeding essentially the life
pressure and um but they told us never
to use it and so like no one knew how to
use this [__] but like guys are getting
like shot the [__] every day yeah and
like you're just like what you're like
relying on a Corman to come save the day
to save your friends but as I progressed
you know they started to like oh now
everyone's get trained in this and
Special Operations you do all sorts of
different Advanced Training medical
training um even down to like live
tissue type of stuff and you you're now
a force multiplier in yourself you can
now sustain life for the most part you
know stop bleeding basic basic life-
saving stuff uh which you know 10 years
ago that was like an unheard of thing so
10 years ago Corman also had like
pistols right you know like that was
because they're not a fighter they're
not a combatant yeah and then that
changed very quickly when combat
outranked your uh desire to to be a
position yeah so I just want you to know
man how much I appreciate you doing this
man and how big of an honor it is uh for
me and and I want you to know this
conversation could be whatever the [__]
you want to be you got anything for me
you know throw it out there's no good
and bad here so I just want to start out
with just like pure [__] gratitude
man I just want to throw that your way
thanks man I really appreciate that um
of course one thing I'm like dumbfounded
with and I'm like sitting here listening
to you and I'm also like getting
emotional I'm like everyone in this room
is going to be dead one day you know and
people are so scared to like share an
ounce of themselves and I just I kind of
feel like I feel like it's my duty this
like this internal calling I don't know
why you know I have my demons I'm I have
my things I'm a turd at you know I'm not
I don't walk perfect perfect but I just
feel so C just to share and like you're
being pissed today good share the world
that you're pissed today like you you
don't know what the [__] you're going on
you're scared share it to the world and
everyone's in the world I live in what I
see is everyone's always trying to put
this like perfect thing out there and
like I'm like what does perfect mean
[__] perfect we're not it I'm not it and
when I try to do it I realize that I'm
so further against who I am and when I
try to like fall into like someone
else's teaching or program I'm like I
have this burning desire to like break
away not because I'm a rebel I am in my
own way but it's just like I know the
way and the way is just to let [__]
go and no matter how many times like I
try to prepare like my very first
speaking engagement talking to Josh he's
like he he told me hey what did you
learn or he's like what you thought it
was what you really found out it to be
and what you took away from and I'm like
oh that's a great structure so I started
writing this [__] down and I could not
remember I have TBI like a [__]
but like I could not remember to save my
life and I'm like [__] because if I have
one opportunity to impact just one
person they don't kill themselves or
they they they invest themselves in some
capacity like that's that's my duty to
like perform Under Pressure that's what
a professional does and uh but I'm like
I could not remember this thing so you
know I go on the stage with no plan like
none and just like I'm I'm gifted in a
way you know but I think everyone's
gifted they just let go and but isn't
that it I mean like that is your mission
right your mission is if I can only just
[__] influence one person like that's
Noble there's something Noble about that
like that that's that's a beginning like
I often think like just take one sort of
inherent truth like take that step
whether it's walking in a stage like I'm
not going to sit here and act like I
know at all what it's like to walk into
combat but I imagine it's the same thing
whether it's the person next to you
whether it's some sort of core belief
whether it's just like I'm just going to
[__] try to stay alive like whatever
that is um just like take that first
step and that core belief and go at it
with everything you have fear is fear
overcoming is overcoming and that's what
I was try to relate to people is like
they're like oh especially men in the
military now I'm getting the law
enforcement world that they're just
they're so insecure they they were this
this Mass this Persona and I get it I've
done the same thing but they don't even
see themselves and they don't work in
environments where they fostered with
like hey dude you doing okay or hey
you're kicking ass for I just want to
say thank you because adab boys don't
exist in like the alpha Savage
environment and um but a lot of these
people think they haven't done enough
and I asked them like what is enough I
literally had a guy at my first speak
engagement 1500 people there I'm getting
miked up and he's like hey man thanks
for what you do bro he's like I I
haven't done everything that you've done
you haven't done that much I'm like bro
I'm like what are you doing here he's
like oh I run this like if you've been
wounded as a law enforcement officer
he's got like this like nonprofit setup
he's like yeah I was shot seven times
with an AR with with an AR or an AK or
some [__] like that I'm just like you
were shot Seven [__] times bro and
you don't think you've done enough like
what is enough this other guy came up to
me Cody I haven't done anything crazy
like you he's like but uh you know I
know my wife she dm' me his wife dm' me
sent me a picture he had her sent
because at his house picture of like a
bullet in his [__] skull I'm like
what is not enough and so take the war
or or combat or crazy [__] out of it and
just how many people don't feel like
they're enough and just I'm a good mom
I'm a good dad I'm a [__] good dog
owner like it's just like why do we live
in this like hell but people are like
I'm going to go to heaven one day I'm
like [__] you're going to you're in
hell right now there is no Heaven
because you can't even see where that
you're living in this opportunity to to
to be why do you think people do that
because it's because they don't feel
worthy people are great at
self-sabotaging it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy you know it's like it's you
know what makes a successful person
successful I'll [__] know because
I've talked a [__] ton of them and
they're so empty inside you know so what
is the key what's the root what is
everyone looking for and I think they're
looking for themselves and you know I
think there's just like power I've also
realized this and I've been stepping
into this power myself more like you
know [__] it dude just like my hat [__]
I'm do you like like I can have a my own
belief I can have my own philosophy my
own ideology like there's all these
different religions and Cults and gangs
and clicks and Social Clubs like because
they have a philosophy and ideology so
why can't I have mine and mine is this
like this journey this like this
undeniable calling you have inside to
like just become more and whether phase
of life you're in you know what your
become more is like you might have this
like I want these external materialistic
things or this I want to be this
personally from myself one day but you
know what that battle is inside and the
true test of a man or woman is like can
you can you address that and face that
and uh that's where I've been finding
myself in the past like three to four
years and it's [__] the hardest thing
I've ever done yeah because it's like
you know God Consciousness whatever
those thoughts that come to your mind
you're like how does it know it knows
when you find the truth it's loud as
[__] right yeah cuz you know and it's
like okay it's easy to like be act
badass you know outside of you but to to
be badass inside you know literally what
the shirt is if you want peace prepare
for war like you want you want the dream
life the whatever these external things
are you but do you got to do the work on
the inside because I've had so many
clients that I've worked with or just
people I interacted with that they have
all the [__] on the outside world but
they're so empty inside because they're
all looking for fulfillment they're like
I've accomplished all these things
what's next and I know that feeling you
I left the military the Pinnacle of
everything and I was so like lost and
scared and hurt if you had a gun to my
head said you got to figure out what
you're going to do I'd be [__] dead
um so I know what it's like to to
accomplish a lot of things and be a high
performer um and then feel just like why
am I even here like what's the purpose
of this suffering that I'm doing I've
already done everything I'm supposed to
do um but to me that's when like your
journey truly starts I have this like
belief that like you're not supposed to
see the path you know each you create
the path each step and whatever path
you're on is the one that you're
supposed to be on they're not all pretty
you know sometimes it leads to the
places full of regret remorse fear the
unknown death even but that's the power
of this thing called like free will you
can truly choose the path that you want
to take that's right and uh once you do
that enough you're like damn this sucks
when you get tired of hitting that same
wall you're like maybe I change it up
and that's when the fun kind of like
becomes because I was on a very downward
trajectory uh internally I was very
self-destructive and I was
self-destructing a lot of people around
me um so really really changing that
whole perspective
of I don't know man you're going to
[__] die what do you want to do yeah
you know cuz I never really believed it
can you just kind of like walk me
through like your sort of desire to join
the military what you thought that was
and kind of like your decision to to be
a marine and then sort of how the
reality of combat set in and what that
meant to you and what and what that
reality he was yeah yeah um so I
originally wanted to be an Army Ranger
it was like the first poster I saw like
this like daycare that I was at it was a
cool guy poster man I was just like a
this thing is sick one day I saw that
movie sniper with Tom Binger yeah and I
was like what that looks crazy and he's
by himself just allly [__] I'd like
watch all these like uh documentaries on
the History Channel or like all these
like Navy SEAL Bud classes I'm like D I
want to be a scout sniper all this like
talk about like from the history of the
snipers and like how it's super super
hard to make it and I was like I didn't
really have a passion for the water so
like going the buds route really didn't
make sense to me and I literally only
joined because I wanted to be a sniper
it looked hard as [__] and it said that
people don't can't all pass it and
looking back at my life now I know why
why successful people are bred from just
the right amount of childhood trauma uh
not too much where it puts you like
drugs and like
self-destruction but enough to where you
feel like you got to prove something and
um I loved my dad a lot and I've been
doing a lot of like healing from like
childhood trauma with my dad nothing bad
at all my dad was a good man my Dad
loved me how he knew how to love me sure
um but I never got like I'm proud of you
I love you and was always looking to get
like my make my dad proud and um like
dude if I do some hard ass [__] like
he's going to think it's dope that was
never really my underlining but when I
looked back and asked myself like how
were you able to do all this type of
[__] like what was the the catless of
like always pushing forward I think that
fuel came from that moment in life I was
always like I was always interested in
like the team stuff I was like never
really good at football but I love the
camaraderie the motivating type of stuff
I love the hard things that I had no
control over because I could sit on the
couch and watch Jared Springer you know
um but I joined and I wanted to be a
scout sniper that was literally it so
you know 9911 happened I was in Spanish
class and everyone like seeing 911 on TV
like I didn't join for America
patriotism uh I would have joined if
there was no war um I just I wanted to
do do this thing I felt so called to do
and everything in my life really like
kind of led up to it I remember sacking
uh groceries at a grocery store and this
like weird dude walked up and he was
like you have really deep set eyes I bet
you'd be a great shot I'm just like did
you hear that [__] I'm supposed to be a
sniper yeah supposed to happen you know
and like I made my ghillie suit like I
just watched The History Channel this
before YouTube AOL I think didn't even
come out yet like made my my ghilly suit
I'm in the backyard like shooting little
green soldiers um I was just into that
silence and I don't know it just seemed
like so much discipline you needed to
like do something so hard like that and
that really drove me so and that
connection sorry to interrupt you but
that connection with your pops like when
you're in selection courses when you go
on through the military and and you
start like bumping up against like real
hardship and things that are like [__]
like this is [__] hard is there a
voice in your head that you can maybe
consciously or subconsciously sort of is
it your dad's voice is it like no never
honestly the old dad thing just I kept
on looking back at my life I'm always
reflecting uh I I try to at least cuz I
find life very fascinating cuz like
there was a time I literally didn't I
knew it was going to die one day
everyone knows but I I never put any
weight behind it I'm like why am I
playing small like if I want to go start
this B I'm going to go start it if I
want to go say hey have have a great day
or go [__] yourself I'm going to go say
those things like you know I I have some
like EQ you know I I keep my [__]
together I'm not a complete jerk but at
the same time like why am I going to
hold myself back but it was really me
with my dad I looked back and I remember
I came back from my second combat
deployment and I went to go visit my
family in Texas and I'm like sitting on
my dad's like wanted to sit on his lap
in this big ass like my parents like old
school they had this like The Lazy Boy
cordoy Lazy Boy chairs cers I remember
like sitting on the side and I just like
wanted to like lay on my dad you know I
just I just I love my dad you know I
just found but I'm I'm a dude that's
like I've I've hurt people and I've been
in Crazy environments and I'm still like
looking for that like I love you and and
like I said um I think after looking
back at all these parts of my life I'm
like oh [__] you know I think I was
always I just wanted my dad his love and
then it also came part of the healing
process of like rumoring that the dude
loved me the best way he could he never
abused me never said I was a piece of
[__] he never not encouraged me that's
right and that was healing also I don't
even know you know you hear about
childhood trauma you're like what the
[__] is childhood trauma um but you
don't need anything crazy just like PTSD
you're depression you don't have to go
to war for that [__] you don't have to
be raped or beat up you just have to
have have something happen that changed
the trajectory of your life and it could
be big or small and uh but that was it
yeah there was really no voice other
than just like I just could not I I had
this voice of like I got to do more I
want to be better so boot camp was like
super chill easy it was a means to an
end so I like it was like a movie you
know I watched everything I could not to
like game the game but like
to why wouldn't I mhm I imagine you
research people before you go play a
role sure so I'm my life is a game I
didn't also I didn't know all that as a
younger kid but like I visualized it
every day I had a vision board it was
Scout snipers and Classics that's all
was in my board what happened when I
joined the Marine Corps I was a scout
sniper I had nothing but Classics like I
just been living out these like
manifestations as a young age not
knowing what a vision board is not
knowing what the power of visualizing
what you actually want to do and more
importantly having this drive that's why
life is kind of challenging now other
than like wanting just to help people
start living um cuz that was a very
powerful thing at a young kid at a young
age like dude this is all I think about
specif goals all my friends like most
people won't even tell their people that
they want to start a business because
they're worried about being judged I'm I
don't give a [__] we're eating fries
with mustard in in the lunch break I'm
like dude I'm be a scout sniper they're
like military stupid you know like you
know I'm going to go to like whatever
just like dumb High School loser stuff
right um yeah so join the military was
it was
exciting all I wanted to do you know you
know I know you know eventually you w
you wound up in fuia and and and but but
can you just talk about sort of you know
like the the realities of War and what
was sort of your first kind of
experiences with with combat and and how
did that kind of far up to what you your
expectations versus the
reality man I was excited to go do my
job I was on a sniper team I was excited
to go perform my duties outside of Camp
Pendleton California yeah you know I
remember before we actually but the
reality of war was that oh look I'm on a
base we have shitty food perfect we have
water that's rational already this is
great um and then like the first like 72
hours there like couple of my leadership
and my team get like hit by a grenade
they're doing like a left seat right
seat like U with outgoing army unit and
I'm like oh [__] you I've never seen
anyone injured you know other than like
just basic training stuff and I'm like
these guys got hit with a [__]
grenade I'm like holy [__] that's real
and then um and what's that feeling man
like what's that is it it's like you're
there but there's like this thing like
with Brotherhood and Sisterhood right
like it's like a shared weight so you're
not holding the whole burden of fear
alone because you know everyone inside
has got like [__] they have that feeling
I can only imagine I mean I can tell you
every time I've ever suited up to go out
the door
um it's not taken lightly you know no
one's taking it lightly no one's joking
uh and if there's any joking leading up
to it you know that there's that there's
that pause before you exit and you're
you're you're becomeing someone
different um you have
to and so you the reality of War for me
the the how it kind of came about was I
had to write it we all had to like write
a death letter I was like [__] like a
death letter this dude comes in it's
like you guys got to write these letters
I'm
like okay and so I kind of like Gaff it
off cuz like I don't I don't know what
to say I write some shitty letters to my
mom and dad and I write one to my my
girl girl from the time in meaningful
but I'm 18 I don't know what meaningful
is I have no idea like what reality is
out there for me and um you know that
day particular my very first deployment
you know that's it was a new frontier
for me I remember we pulled outside the
city of flua we loaded up at like 3:00
in the maybe 3 4:00 in the morning super
dark outside and people are smoking you
see red lights and we get this back back
of the seven tons and it just loud and
just smells like diesel fuel everywhere
and but it's quite as [__] yeah and um
we leave the base and they called it the
Clover Leaf it was the this like highway
system right outside the fujia it was
just down the road maybe like 8 to 10
minutes and so you're like your bumpy
ride getting there still quiet as [__]
and they tell us to get out the trucks
and it's super dark super quiet but we
have these like street lights above us
and a couple guys like start shooting
out these lights it's not like the
movies like there was took a few shots
for these things to happen and I think a
couple of shots probably missed uh but
it was like my first gunshots ever heard
like outside the wire not on a range and
so that was little heightened level and
and it's just so quiet and what's even
crazier fua specifically they were
dropping flyers from the sky like days
and weeks prior talking about hey you
have X amount of days to get out of the
city if you're left here you'll be
viewed as a combatant hey there's a
curfew like it was there was a lot of
Preparatory work that went into this a
lot of scups um and how how did you
think you were going to be received like
you I mean so what's odd was that our
training for this particular deployment
back at home was called SAS it was like
uh security and stability operations and
so we're like doing checkpoints
basically like martial law type of stuff
and um like you were being sent to like
police the area and basically you
thought you would be like kind of
welcomed I don't know about welcome but
we were there to like police the area
and that definitely was like not that
was the mindset for the training back at
home that's what our unit was doing that
wasn't the reality we faced out there I
mean the army guys were just getting
hammered the whole time they're out
there uh no one knew what to expect it's
like the whole like madisha thing no one
really knew the horn storm that was
about to be stirred up yeah and uh I
remember us pushing into the City and um
being the snipers we we LED everyone uh
always kind of like the Ford observers
type of stuff and I remember seeing uh
we had these Mercedes iabs these like
small little Mercedes Jeeps that our
weapons guys had like machine guns and
like Mark 19s like grenade launchers in
the back
I saw one of those get hit with a
[__] rocket I was like holy [__] like
it's just silent still even though
that's so loud it's still silent it's
just so it was like Eerie you're like
couple shots nothing happens I mean
something blows up people get hurt and
you're like [__] that's intense but
you're kind of like in the zone so you
just keep on going and you that kind of
repeats itself until you're you're faced
with conflict where you can't just keep
on going anymore right so like a lot of
things were still kind of like harassing
at this point point of time in the day
but it was like holy [__] I just saw
something blow up I just saw some dudes
get [__] up like oh [__] and next
thing I'm told him like Hey we're
patrolling down here we're hitting this
next house and we're going to go set up
an OverWatch position and I'm the point
man so I'm like super excited but it's
also like super intense and it's a very
Urban environment which we didn't do a
lot of urban training uh and fighting in
the urban world is [__] there's Urban
movement is very scary uh there's a lot
of uh unknowns that can happen was it
what you did you expect it like was it
what did it look like the way that you
expected like I'm sure you IM you could
have said you could have said you're
going to anywhere and I would have been
like what does that mean you know
technology wasn't a thing I couldn't
Google what fujia was there was no
Instagram videos of War you know there
was you know fujia was like the main
thing you know that people talk about
since like Vietnam like the most
gnarliest fighting o-1 which I was not a
part of I think I was still in high
school and that happened you know 2001 I
graduated 2003 According to some of the
guys that were there it was crazy there
was like there was there was death there
was destruction but it was different it
was not
as insane I had no idea what that meant
right because I had no comparable fuia
was [__] insane it was like out of
all my deployments it was still by far
the craziest
scariest um one I've ever done in my
life uh absolutely [__]
terrifying and uh which is cool in a way
I guess you know I survived that [__]
and I'm able to like articulate and and
hopefully Empower people uh with that
type of background and credibility I
guess to like help people like yeah
better yourself and [__] but at the time
I'm [__] 18 I'm not thinking about
tomorrow I'm worried about today and um
I remember that my day one in the city
was uh March
26 and um we hit this building uh we set
up an OverWatch position on the second
floor our job was to
basically um set up an OverWatch
position U report back anything we saw
and then the the other squads we're
going to start pushing forward and we're
just clearing like a big line through
the city and my raadar operator and I
set up next to this window and my my
team leader my assistant team leader
they're both School train Scout snipers
so they had a bolt gun and a pistol so
we clear this big H this big house we go
upstairs we set up we're like super
sneaky squirly and um I'm holding
Security on the door that's what
appointment does and I was used to that
because I've done this a few times now
in this daytime and I just wanted to get
in the fight I'm I wanted to participate
and like do my job but I'm I have a very
important job Mak sure people don't come
up behind us and like murder us and my
radar operator is uh he sets up the
radio by the window and he calls out
these two dudes that are across the
street with guns and so I I come to the
window and this is like when all hell
breaks out uh we just started just
getting like pelted into a room uh
machine gun
rifles um and now I'm in a gunfight it's
very loud I'm in an urban building
that's very Hollow it's under
construction so every shot is like
verting through the house you have no
hearing protection so like it's potently
loud um my heart's
racing and it's very violent at this
point to the point where like my my
assistant team leader my team leader
they're in the prone in the on the floor
because they they can't engage they have
a [__] sniper rifle and they're
fighting a machine gun and we're already
like vectored into this like one little
opening in a
window and so uh Ben was his name or is
his name he was on the right side of the
window I was on the left side of the
window and we're basically taking turn
shooting with our M4 or M16s and I shoot
Ben shoots I'm like I go to reload and
um I reload my gun and we're fighting
these guys probably like 25 yards away
across the street I call it like a pet
boys Building there's like a bunch of
mufflers and a couple like old rusted
cars on top it looked like it was like a
Pet Boys in
Iraq um and I reload as soon as I come
across the window pop back out I just
lights out I hear this like loud like
this like life like leave my body and uh
I had this out of- body experience
during a gunfight and um I didn't really
know what that was but I could I could
just remember seeing I thought it was
dead and I could just I could see my
body I could see the gunfight I don't
know if you ever played a video game
where like you see like the glitch and
you can see like through the walls or in
the rooftop that's what I was seeing I
see the the fighting across the street I
can see my house I can see my body I can
see my team I can see the stairwell
leading up to the room I can see the
smoke billing I see all this [__] and
then um I was like [__] my life is
over I'm I'm I'm thinking this and then
I literally get sucked back into this
light and I come back into my body and I
come back to like convulsing and [__]
and um my my my assistant team leader
he's like kicking me on the ground he's
in the prone he's like dude I thought
you were [__] dead and I I like came
to like crying and laughing like what
the [__] just happened they're like dude
we thought you were dead we didn't see
any blood I'm like [__] and I don't I
don't know what's really going on at
this point I literally thought I was
just dead my head hurts like a
[__] and they're like dude you
got to get on the radio and call well my
body dropped next to the radio so I'm
like Scurry next you know a couple
couple feetish to this radio and I I
start my radio transmission and it's
like it's bad it's it's bad like uh in
between like uh Transmissions we say the
word break so you know I'm still talking
so you don't step on me CU we're all
using the same channel I'm like War I
think it was like Warhammer or gunm
smoke break this is break
Grim Reaper break like I'm just I'm like
everything is a break and we're getting
nobody and uh we try this for like what
seems like an eternity um and we're like
my team leers like we got to get the
[__] out of here so we we break down our
position we're still getting shot at
it's now sporadic now because you don't
have an exact target they're just
shooting their building we're still
getting some rounds through a window and
our biggest concern now is that they're
going to come collect their kill and so
they don't know I'm dead but they've
been shooting this window right they're
probably we're not shooting back anymore
at this point so we're kind of just like
building out what the future scenario
would look like we can't stay here
people know where we're at so we get
downstairs and I remember we set up like
a we set up a radio in like this
bathroom we're trying to get another
transmission and I'm holding security
like the main entrance room is over here
I'm in this bathroom my team leader
assistant team leader in this room back
here and I can see this window and it's
elevated because we're the the building
is higher than the surface
level and I just see this like turban
that's all I see is like this much of a
dude's face like walk by I'm like my
heart is just like my heart's racing now
um my heart just like [__] sinks I'm
like like shut the [__] up I'm like
there's a dude shut
up and then I hear steps coming in the
house I'm like [__] and um I see the
shadow get bigger bigger bigger and I
don't know who it is um it ain't one of
our guys uh at least and so this dude
cross the corner I just like blast him
in the face with my muzzle well that was
one dude we there's three more guys
coming to to our house and now we have
four dudes in our [__] house that
aren't us and we're like dude we are so
[__] we got to get the [__] out of
here like there's more coming like
they're just sending probes like we're
thinking the worst case scenario at this
point in time um were they armed or like
they weren't armed which is even crazier
uh but maybe it wasn't crazy this is my
first interaction with any at this point
right first it was like the gunfight and
I'm Sor what what did you get wounded
like what happened so I got shot in the
helmet what the [__] yeah like um it
went like just about an inch above like
the lip of my helmet back in the day if
I was wearing like a newer like
half-head helmet i' I'd been [__]
dead um but the older helmets that we
used to have they had this like lip that
kind of bowed out some and it literally
went right in the divot of the lip dude
yeah it was crazy like my goggles I had
goggles on my [__] cuz that's what you
do right you put goggles on your helmet
and they're like dangling my mvg mounts
like all [__] shot up and it's just
like just dangling right here
and um it it it was crazy so I'm going
through all that I'm I'm very dizzy I'm
very nauseous and now we have like
[__] dudes like my and drillin is
just through the roof everyone's drill
is through the roof uh my team leader
and ATL had their [__] pistols out on
these guys we're like we got to get the
[__] out of here and there's two more
guys that come to our door we're like
get the [__] in here we start pulling
these guys we start crawling them in the
corner because we're like [__] [__] now
we're outnumbered they do anything
stupid like and we hesitate we're all
we're all dead what do these guys have I
didn't know what a su side vest was back
then um I didn't even know what an IID
was back then they didn't really exist
wow um so those thoughts weren't really
in my head
so we finally make my team's like hey we
got to get out of here so we make a call
we try to like hijack a card down the
road that like just a random civilian
car that was driving and we that didn't
really work out for us I thought it
would be super cool and epic we like
take a car and we go back to Friendly
lines that was the worst idea we had uh
cuz we had to expose ourselves to the
middle of the street we don't even know
where these shitthe heads are at we just
got in a gunfight with uh and we're like
[__] it we just start like beat feeding
back uh to where we think friendly lions
are at and we end up running into a
marine Squad that was there and they're
like hey you guys good we're like oh
dude we just got he just got [__]
shot in the helmet and we know we're
we're getting [__] shot over here
like yeah we came up and um we weard
some [__] shooting so we just started
blasting both [__] buildings and I'm
like
what I'm like okay okay but they didn't
really think about it so I go to the cor
I'm like hey dude like I'm [__] up bro
I have this gnarly headache I just got
shot in the helmet like and I'm like
crying still laughing and you know
you're like the cool guy and there's
another guy that got shot through and
through with his ass cheeks and so like
we're like the two cool guys right now
and they're like oh you guys are okay
we're like [__] and uh I get a
cigarette in a moin like it's the stigma
is real right like a cigarette and a
moin and I'm like I'm still [__] up
and uh I'm not even putting two and two
together and uh Delta was doing a a raid
down the street and they they wanted
they wanted outside security outer court
on security so uh we got like the
marching orders to like March down there
and I go to my assistant team leader I'm
like his name is Brian I'm like Brian
I'm [__] up dude he's like pick up
your [__] rifle I'm like [__] D hard
as [__] hard as Nails right I'm like
dragging my gun I'm like holding without
a pistol grip I'm just [__] dragging
like I'm I'm doing my damn just to stay
afloat right now and he's like pick up
your [__] rifle I'm like [__] so I
pick it up I like this like monkey
waddle and um we got to the train tracks
this where we're setting up our sniper
position at and they had it I didn't I
passed out there and um The Raid happens
I come to and uh my captain comes up my
he was like a lieutenant at the time
actually my platoon Commander for the
sniper platoon he's like hey uh we're
going to send you back home we're going
to send you back uh to base to get
checked out I'm like no I want to stay
here uh he's like hey he's like we're
we're leaving in the morning I'm like no
[__] that I'm going to stay here you're
just telling me that [__] he's like dude
all we're doing is setting up a mortar
position tonight and then everyone's
leaving in the morning you have my word
I'm like okay so I go back and I get
checked out that really meant just like
a doc it got documented and sure as [__]
the next morning all of our friendly
forces came back to base and we realized
that there was no plan there was really
no game plan people didn't really
understand what was going to happen
there was no phase lines uh I mean we
were being told to like seize fire with
certain machine guns because the various
calibers were like going through the
city and hitting adjacent units m
um and that's when like the RoR Mill
came to like how I got shot in the
helmet and uh they're like hey we what
if that Squad [__] shot you I'm like
that like really like [__] me up too
I'm like a damn dude like I could have
got killed by my own people and not
everyone has a radio back then being a
sniper team we were very blessed we had
aogs so we had Optics we had radios for
everybody we had night vision for
everybody but the Infantry the the the
grunt squads they didn't have that [__]
like maybe like three people out of like
12 or 13 had an asset like that Looking
Back Now and knowing the combat missions
I've done later on in life with the gear
and equipment that I had to go back to
that environment like damn dog we did
some crazy scary [__] with not a lot of
stuff uh fighting the Urban War without
like lasers and lights and night vision
that's it's [__] terrifying you know
um because you have no advantage and um
so that really set the tone for that
deployment for me I'm like damn dude I
got 7 months left to this [__] and I
already like fa like this like big like
I could have died and it definitely like
terrified me a bit but at the same time
it was like it's exciting still because
like you can be scared all you want to
you ain't going nowhere right so might
as well like embrace it and um yeah that
but that was a good tone for the
deployment in Looking Back Now just I
think how lucky I am that that even
happen just even have that story alone
help Forge and shape me who I am you
know decade and a half later that would
bring me to my knees um but I never
would have got to where I'm at today if
it wasn't for you know that particular
day that kind of set everything up for
me but yeah fuia was a uh Beast um
actually 30 days after that day uh April
26 we were at this point in time we're
inside the city of Fallujah uh we
stopped doing like these clearing
operations and the new marching orders
was that um we're going to become the
Anvil so the company I was supporting
was Echo company second Battalion first
Marines
and it was our job basically all the
other units around fuia their whole
purpose was to send Fighters towards us
and they do that by Bas basically
pinching them and compressing them and
and making them like egress and they
come to us and we' do what we have to do
and um so we were the main effort for
our Battalion so all the other companies
in our Battalion were also doing the
same thing pushing guys towards us they
were setting up strong arms U blocking
positions and basically funneling
Fighters toward towards where we were at
and at this point in time uh these three
Delta sniper teams come down we like hey
you know I'm like a little kid I'm like
wow Delta Force you know like all all I
knew was like Chuck Norris you know and
these guys are all like they have like
forward racing hats and like beards and
like revolvers with scopes on it I'm
just like and like Star truck I'm like
damn you guys are The Real McCoy and uh
they're like hey we heard you guys were
like in some crazy [__] we thought we
come out here and and help out and we
were absolutely in the crazy [__] every
day and so uh our company Commander his
name was Doug zimbeck he's like he
wanted to do this like U this sniper
Mission so we kept on taking sniper
shots from this one particular building
across the cemetery the Jolan Cemetery
that that was right outside of our house
and he's like I want to take over that
position I want to Ambush these [__]
I want to bring the fight to them and
we're like yeah let's do it so we create
this Mission we leave early in the
morning uh the Salters like blow a
rocket through through one of the
ancient walls and we we go through it we
clear this building and we found a bunch
of weapons cachets in there we found um
where they were shooting from shooting
at us from they had this big spider hole
like a loophole familiar with that no
basically like um chiseling out like
this spiderweb spiral like a funnel from
inside of a building outside so you have
a small hole on the outside but on the
inside you have a big hole uh so you can
Traverse and you know change your
trajectory um so you can still they're
they're so they can still shoot us but
we're like where the [__] did it come
from loophole murder hole various names
for him yeah bunch of bunch of uh ammo
bunch of weapons and we're like damn
this is definitely the house so like
that that intel was good right visually
good and uh so my tyer snipers Team sets
on the rooftop machine gunner set up on
the rooftop and we're knocking out our
own murder holes uh so we can still be
back from the wall and not be exposed
too much and my team lead is like hey
it's hot as [__] up here how about you
you and um the radio operator go
downstairs and we'll come get you in
like an hour and so we're like okay cool
my my braid operator leaves his rifle up
there with their assistant team leader I
asked my team Le hey do you want my
rifle he's like no if anything happens
you're going to need it that's probably
the best advice that dude ever said wow
um we go down we're like our flax are
off we're like smoking cigarettes and
shooting the [__] talking about home and
like hot or not was big back then like
all these dumb things Myspace was
popping right um and uh then then hell
hell came very quickly uh our building
uh grenad started going off on the
rooftop
and our building just started getting
lit up with machine guns and RPGs and
grenades and it was very violent very
fast like very calculated uh not seratic
very uh methodical and um in our
particular room we were in we were they
had these like um like sleeping social
rooms where there's just like walls full
of mattresses and this is the room we
were in and so rpk like just lights up
our our wall our back wall uh where the
door is that we entered our room so like
we're like kind of like red out against
the wall grenades are flying into her
room [__] um and the building adjacent
to us was literally uh probably from
this couch to that wall right behind you
like it's very like you can jump into it
and that's exactly what they were doing
they were uh jumping to our rooftop they
were jumping into Windows they coming to
a front door it was it was like an all
out like overrun assault it was crazy no
one really knew the Dynamics of the
severity of it cuz we're all on we're on
like three different levels rooftop
second floor and bottom floor you were
there how many what how many of you were
there we had a full I think we had like
a like two squads there so 25 plus
people yeah uh and then I just remember
like screaming and like yelling and all
this is crazy [__] and uh my homie Ben
and I we finally make it out of this
room it's just that quiet is back but
all hell is breaking loose but it's so
quiet at the same it's weird such a
weird feeling um but you just hear
screaming you hear support Corman yeah
get that cover that pick up that and
then spaic fire from inside of our house
shooting out so that's even louder
because now it's inside your house
you're shooting out and then now you
hear about all the hey we need we need
guys in the rooftop and at the same time
I see literally like four Dudes come
down one's missing an arm one's missing
a leg one's [__] peppered through his
his face and his body and uh my
assistant team leader and my my team
leader my two snipers in the team they
come down all [__] up fragmentation in
the face and in the side of their body
uh and I'm like holy [__] and it's still
happening up there people are still
fighting up there so this whole time was
really based about like taking care of
the Wounded getting we didn't have any
stretchers so we're like banging down
doors and they're carrying people and
there's just a lot of [__] pain and
just the stench of like death and um but
that silence is still there just this
like nothing Silence of the Mind only
thing that exists is like what your face
right now and you you even know if
you're going to make it out of that but
you just keep on going cuz you have
what's your other option and so and
that's when I saw my first case of like
fog of war and like shell shock I saw
this dude I came when I came out of this
room he was a senior guy than me and he
was like on a knee just
like not [__] moving wow and not one
second do I think he was scared yeah um
I don't think anything negative of him
I'm like I tapped him show him like Hey
bro let's go and he didn't move right
away I I ended up moving they um they
said um they needed more support on the
rooftop and one of my best friends he
befriended me he was a senior guy he was
a senior machine gunner his name is
Aaron Austin he was on the rooftop
working his machine gun and uh he got
[__] he got blasted a few times in
the chest and uh they're like aon's hid
and I'm like [__] and so I just like I
run up this [__] stairwell and I'm
like dude I'm gonna [__] die like
it's it was pretty terrifying and I go
up there I just see that he's like white
as [__] and um but you can't like focus
on him him you there's a fight going on
so uh there's another guy up there his
name was uh I think Charlie was his
first name but Gomez his last name um I
think he got a silver star from the
event he got like like half his shoulder
went away got blasted with an AK and the
guy that I tapped on the shoulder I'm
like hey dude come on let's [__] go I
saw him up on the rooftop actually
almost shot him in the [__] head I
was uh shooting I was on a knee we were
taking contact from the Minette so uh a
mosque was right there and we weren't
allowed to engage on mosque uh so they
used that to their advantage to the
mosque had a drop on this particular
building so now we're fighting guys from
The High Ground And in the Level Playing
Field plus they're coming from the
bottom
floor and I'm aiming up and shooting and
this guy literally just runs right in
front of my land of sight and thank God
I had like Trigger Discipline like it
was it was crazy but it just happened so
[__] fast and uh throwing grenades
back from our
rooftop uh like some straight movie [__]
but you're in the movie now yeah and um
we we drag Aaron down
and we tried to salvage as much
equipment there was a sniper rifle live
up there there was a couple of bags our
one main machine gun was all like
burning we had all of our grenades were
up there like our 40 m millimeter
grenades um for our two or three or
grenade launcher they're all [__]
exploding and ammo popping here and
there and we try to salvage as much gear
as we could and we bring down Aaron and
we're like we got to get the [__] out of
here and so the platoon Commander at the
time they he he's coordinating uh Cobra
gunships come in and support us he's
he's coordinating Abram tanks to come
the only way we made it out of that
house is cuz Abram tanks they came
outside they took the Brun of the
fighting uh why we just kind of like
scurried behind them and like made it
down in Alleyway and I call it like the
MoGo dii mile that we did running back
and it was this Delta Medic named Dan
Dan myself and Ben my radio operator
were holding Aaron and uh managing this
IV
line and Aaron's like you know he's he's
talking about his mom he's talking about
his
fiance and you're just you're I just
wanted to cry
um but you just you're just I don't
carrying a body is the hardest thing
I've ever done and I've done it a few
times in my life and it's like not easy
um it's it's a lot of weight and see he
was like why does that cup you know why
does this cup and I'm just like [__] and
I didn't know much about medical [__]
like I know now and um I'm I was very
reliant on Medics and cormen to do their
job and uh
we we make it back to the fighting
position our stronghold and our um one
of the bosses like get the [__] up there
you like we we we the fighting still
going on and Eric uh Aaron gets passed
off to the Corman and they're waiting
for uh
medac well around the same time uh our
Command um this is the disconnect that
we were talking about our Command is
common to get in the [__]
mix uh so our Battalion Commander our
Battalion sergeant major and like their
command cronies are taking our medic
vehicles to come to us so they're
they're basically utilizing assets that
we need that we didn't have and uh we
needed we needed Aaron and all these
other guys to get sent back to the mech
the mech was I forget what the acronym
stands stood for but it was like a
bigger base they had a more military
units there and they had like a like a
trauma unit there and uh Aaron Aaron
died like on the way to the mech
um and you're you find out about that
later on I mean we're fighting into the
night time back at our stronghold
position and um I now I'm assuming a
sniper rifle cuz both my snipers and my
team are are [__] hit and I took my
team leader gun I started uh going to
work with it and um you know that
changed that changed everything the
whole dynamics
of really reality that was that I've
never been more scared in my life uh
like absolutely [__] terrified I mean
to the point where I've seen grow men
who've done Somalia and o1 my team
leader actually he was told by the we
didn't know this cuz we were upstairs
fighting and throwing [__] grenades
the platoon Commander for the Infantry
Squad that we were supporting apparently
he told my team leader to get upstairs
he's said get up there and go fight with
your men and apparently he told them I'm
not going anywhere with a [__]
pistol that day I saw Corman kill people
with pistols they're running out of
ammunition with pistols um and this guy
he was like
done and it just it really changed my
perspective of of like brutality and and
like what
why what am I doing what is this for
what is war what is the deployment like
what are all these [__] things that
we're doing those Delta guys flew out
that night they're like dude this is
this is crazy they were all shot to [__]
too a couple of those guys were wounded
they're like dude that was [__] crazy
and
um that was only month two of a seventh
month deployment
dude and so being like now I'm now I'm
uh now I'm 19 it like really set the
stage
and I remember like a few weeks later
the first sergeant there he's like doing
like morale calls for everybody he's
like gave us a satellite phone and he's
like hey when's the last time you call
home like I [__] before I came out of
here he's like call home now I'm like
I'm good he's like no [__] call call
your family so I pick up the sa phone
and your voice is already like kind of
jumbled you sound like a robot and I'm
like hey Mom she's like what I'm like
Mom she's like what I'm like it's your
son she's like oh my God she starts
losing her [__] and uh I come to find
out that cuz a month earlier I was shot
in the helmet I was also put on the Kia
list and so my mom got notified that I
was dead but nothing ever there was no
people that came to the house there was
like nothing follow on that happened so
for 30 days my mom and dad thought I was
[__] dead shut the [__] and um I'm
like dude where's I'm not getting like
letters like no nothing's happening
right cookies like but it's also like
you know out there just like any
confined space where you really have no
control of like a day seems like a
[__] week a week seems like a year
just cuz you're committed to it um and
she told me this [__] and I'm I'm like
I'm a I'm a lance corpal I'm 19 years
old now like no one I'm not going to
complain what what am I going to
complain about um but I also saw like
the stupid like that's absolutely
[__] absurd and stupid and then I saw
the stupidity of like the battlefield of
like these idiots that same day you know
we're waiting for the medac uh these
people the leadership comes for a
position and um there was like rumors
like hey you know we found out that
Aaron died and they're talking about
like the pon command was like I'm
putting an Aaron in for this award and
the sergeant major um he came up to me
on the rooftop and I'm bloody from head
to toe my gun's bloody I'm bloody and uh
I'm like hey Sergeant Major uh I heard
that they're might be putting in Aaron
for an award he's like bronze stars are
reserved for staff and cosos and hire
and then he told me to uh unbl my
sleeves um I rolled up my sleeves
because the sweat and the blood was like
overtaking my grip and I'm trying to
grip a [__] human body as I'm running
for all of our lives and uh those are
the two things out of his
mouth and that that was really the first
reality check of like there's multiple
Wars going on and I've had some type of
interaction like that on every combat
deployment I've ever been on um where
there's a complete
disconnect um but there's that that a
spr of cor and that discipline and the
and the doctrine and all these things
but but that's what we say really a life
is worth is not worth an award because
of a rank you know and that's not even a
policy you know and the first thing out
of your mouth is like hey Marine are you
good to go no it's like unroll my
sleeves dude
um it just it's it's just it's
comical that you can go through all that
type of stuff and then they expect you
to go right back to being a [__]
robot and complying and um subject to
just idiocracy you know I'm not I I
don't have any discontent with the
military I did it best thing I ever did
with my life I the people everything but
I learned so much I learned that you're
in any Institution there's a rank
structure you're a [__] number uh any
institution where there's um there's
leadership there's disconnect uh any any
institution that has um doers and
speakers you're going to have ripples uh
you're going to have ripples in that
pool because there's people living a
different life and I don't expect this
[__] guy to like know that you know I
just lost my best friend I I didn't
expect this guy to know like an ounce of
like what I went through or what any us
went through but just a little the
[__] nod you know and like doesn't
exist then you're like why why why why
am I doing this you know what's the
point um you know I start to have those
thoughts later on in my military career
because it always seemed that it always
seemed that when the boys go down range
they go out the
wire they're you're really on your own
yeah you might have support um but you
come back home to a [__] different
you come back home to like your base to
your command structure and they they're
not fighting the same War you're
fighting they're worried about your
haircut they're worried about why isn't
your TPS report submitted on time they
they don't give a [__] how should they
and why would they when they're never
when that's not bred in a community
Common Sense isn't bred you can't teach
that [__] I've been to like almost all
the leadership courses they had uh in
the military and I find leadership
courses very comical because they're
teaching doctrine that was written so
long ago and they don't invoke the power
of free thinking and Common Sense and uh
like we were talking about like with
acting like being able to like adapt and
overcome not just be so rigid and
structured when the when the rules no
longer provide any value what do you do
you have to do something and and people
just they don't have that it's not a
common thing I I realize a lot of people
give a lot of credit to um you know the
military there's a lot of brave men and
women and they're there for multiple
[__] reasons uh but not everyone's a
rocket scientist you know and uh you
don't need a degree for that you just
need to have a pulse and realize yeah
this smells like [__] and we should
probably do it differently but that goes
against the grain because the military
thrives on and very successful because
of the structure because of the the
rules and
regulations uh I'm not saying that we
should throw that all at the window in
Wartime but there's a human aspect about
war you know there's there's there's
there's buttons that are killing people
right um there's drones that are doing
work there's there's robots that are
doing things but there's there's human
operators and you know if you look back
in like old Warrior culture you know
they these old these old tribes these
Native Americans they had medicine they
had healers right they'd come back from
war parties and they they would [__]
heal the person that was looking weird
or staying alone and they would they'd
bring them together as community and
you're like you're like shunn for being
that person now you're being weak or to
speak up and but we call ourselves
[__] Warriors and Savages Alphas all
this type of stuff and it's it's it's
comical and and I say that because no
one can ever take away what I've done so
I I have a very beautiful blessed
traumatic background that has enabled me
to speak and say the things I speak and
say today and without those I would
probably just be a Schmo um because
people like you don't [__] know but I
do know uh I also know what's really
important in in regards to like Warfare
and you know they have this thing in
Special Operations called Soft truths
and it says uh uh I think I'm probably
butchering it but it says like men are
more important than Hardware we have it
blasted on the wall we have all these
soft truths men are more important than
Hardware um what does it say another one
is is like basically like quality over
quantity like all these things you're
like damn those are those are good
principles I support those 100% And then
you see the quite opposite in the system
hey uh I know these guys didn't meet the
standard but we're going to let them all
continue to face two uh you know hey uh
I know this guy he hasn't been the best
team guy but let's go ahead and put him
over there or like you know hey um I
know I've asked a lot from you but I
need you to go on one more rotation
right and we just go against it and so
but yet we're so hardcore these like
rules and regulations but these soft
truth these overarching things we're
like it's more optional and so I just
always was like fber gasta throughout my
career with like that's why I think I
was like extremely successful because I
was outspoken because I've seen all
these horrible things and uh I've seen
the very beautiful things that the
military provides and and the leadership
like [__] man like when you give a
chance for a man woman to like just
truly like
Thrive it's magical I've seen so many
powerful things whether that's on a
Warfare side or just like a support
enabler side um but I've also seen like
the complete opposite where the military
and I'm sure most organizations are full
these things I call them false Idols
where people like oh so and so is
[__] epic they're awesome and then
you know behind the doors they're I
don't care about the personal life I'm
not one to judge your personal life but
like your professional life you know
they're not standing up for their people
uh they're not not speaking up for them
they're like throwing them under the bus
they're not taking care of them and I'm
just like you guys are like idolizing
this dude but like he just let your
whole section get screwed over because
he didn't even go against the commander
and said you know what sir my guys
aren't best utilized that way everyone's
worried about peing the man and I never
understood that in the military I was
always
outspoken um I always felt different I
always like I never felt like I could
just conform with like doing what
everyone else does it was and I I never
did any of that stuff to be rebellious
but I've seen too much I was exposed to
too much and honestly being having that
outof body experience and coming close
to death like that I'm like I'm like why
would I hold myself back and right in
the beginning right I mean that was like
right off the [__] 19 years old and
you have a 15-year career after I mean
what keeps you going in the military
yeah so I remember I was in Sniper
school so I came back from this
deployment and I went to sniper School
uh about like 20 days before everyone
else came back so like seven guys from
my sniper platoon that weren't School
trained guys yet we went back to sniper
school and I find myself in Sniper
school and I'm on the Range we're doing
uh in the and the chief instructor we're
having like a lunch break and we just
got done getting like doing like
mountain climbers and eight8 counts and
all this crazy [__] and he's talking to
us as we're like scarfing food on our
face he's like listen he reenlisted in
front of us and he looked at us and
squar in the [__] face said if you
want to make a [__] difference
reinlist I like and it's stuck with me
ever since a lot of people [__] oh this
place sucks but they don't want to they
don't want to promote to a higher
position to influence their battle space
they want to stay the same cuz it's
comfortable and they're good at it they
don't ever want to like change their
[__] en environment you know defy
their Norm of complacency and comfort
and it stuck with me and so some some
career path that I wanted I had to
extend because you have to have like
okay if you go to this like
multi-million dollar school you have to
have so many years left on your contract
to to serve that they're going to get
their money out of you right um so I
found myself like when to progress in
the military like okay I came back from
my second sniper deployment I wanted to
I I really wanted to go to force
reconnaissance it was like the next
thing for me uh so when I did all that
in a past I had to extend for like two
years uh to fulfill a contract and once
that contract was done I'm like there's
more and so I relisted again and I
realized I was promoting faster the
ranks and I don't know I just I didn't
re I never reenlisted for America my
[__] flag
um definitely not
politics just the dudes man I I love the
dudes uh and there's I saw it I saw it
in boot camp you know I saw it when I
was a py there's there's people that
there's nothing wrong with being like a
follower I think there's a there's a uh
condescending derogatory term of the
follower but not everyone can be the
chief right and I was a chief when I was
never the chief and I was a chief when I
was a chief and was I always good [__]
no man I talked up a lot as a leader I
also learned a lot as a leader and
there's just people that need guidance
and support and they need to be said
like dude you're [__] crushing it bro
I'm proud of you they don't know how to
handle it but they need to hear that if
not you're just going to repeat the
cycle just in a different Avatar yeah
and then nothing ever changes so true
and so um but that was really the callus
for like wanting to stay in is yes there
was like the self-fulfilling thing I
wanted to do I wanted to to be more and
I wanted to especially when I made it to
marlock I wanted to be in charge of my
organization one I could see it I had
plenty of time I knew I could do it uh
and I realized that the guys that were
filling those roles they [__] forgot
it was very political the the really
good guys that could fill those
positions they weren't really liked by
the the officer staff uh the men like
them a lot I mean I only made it as far
as I did because like a a very large
handful of these like super super like
senior guys uh in my organization that
mentored me looked out for me stood up
for me defended me me uh when they
didn't have to and so but those guys
never got those opportunities to be in
charge because they weren't the they
couldn't be bought they couldn't be
bought with fear fu yeah and um you
would see it time and time again these
insecure [__] men forget where they
came from and they get these these high
lank ranking leadership positions and
you know I'm not a believe even if I was
not if I got that opportunity to make
that position not everything is worth
fighting for and that and I learned that
as a leader I'd come up to my guys like
what do you mean you want me to wear an
undershirt I'm like listen bro we're
here to I used to never wear an
undershirt then I became the charge of
my team I'm like listen dude we're going
to be judged in like the first 30
seconds like we're all going to go in
there looking the same because we're
we're bidding for a mission because if
we don't get approve for another team is
going to get this Mission why else would
we do this [__] job I know the
undershirts as dumb as you do gives a
[__] because when I was being told wear
an under like this is [__] stupid
someone a sellout yeah yeah and so as
each rank I realize oh oh okay this
makes sense I also mature more and then
you know I was a Big Jack tattoo guy I
didn't look like a picture perfect
Marine so like I I had to represent my
team the best way I could and these
idiots cared about like how you looked
you know and uh so I did my best to kind
of look that part not I still was me but
I'm like Hey we're at least going to
like look the kind of the same and uh
we're going to present ourselves in a
certain way we're going to have our gear
set up we're going to brief these
[__] morons when they come here a
certain way we're going to greet we're
going to do everything dog and pony to
the next [__] Dimension because no
one's going to question our caliber of
professionalism and the way we can
execute business um because I realized
there's a lot of there's a lot of people
that just talk [__] about the system but
they're not doing thing to do it and
anytime there's a box right the military
is very boxy it's it's it's a structured
you know the lowest rank you know the
highest rank you know the different job
positions you can have in in a career
field and you know the different jobs
that exist in the military so once you
know that that blueprint it's just a
game now how much you want to play it
sure and you know I leveraged a lot of
that with you know like peing behind the
curtain in each phase each level I'm
like okay what are these what are they
looking for what what's keeping guys
from moving forward and a lot of guys
what kept them from doing that was they
just bitched and nothing happened they
weren't willing to defy the norm and
like do something different in that in
that environment and um I remember very
specifically I I've deployed from all
three operational battalions from
marlock and um I served at every one of
them like one of the few guys at the
time that I hit all three of them and I
remember I was part of our Third
Battalion at the time it was like the
bastard Battalion it was like The
Underdogs apparently there was a bunch
of Great Men there I don't know why well
other than then leadership sucked
leadership was horrible dog
trash and I I was I got called back
early from Africa and I'm like hey
you're being redirected to deploy to
Afghanistan you need to come back and
get briefed and you need to start
training so I come back and basically I
was like the sixth course of action that
Maro approved on um to like like who has
the most experience here in this unit uh
what team has the most experience and
has the most time uh so they can go do
this Mission and my team was chosen so I
got some new structure and I got some
new guys in my team and I basically like
got to build it out well we were the
bastard children the whole time I've
been reminded don't [__] this up you
know you guys better not embarrass us
like NOC encouragement I'm just like
whatever I didn't give a [__] if you
give me an opportunity to [__] fail
bro I'm going to take the opportunity
and succeed like it's just everybody
should yearn for an opportunity to fail
because there's opportunity to fail
there's one to succeed absolutely and so
it was like the best training I've ever
did like my teams running everything it
was super sick very self- sustained we
had a lot of support from the command uh
so then we deploy we we go do this
training with our West Coast Brothers
out here and we're getting treated like
bastards bro like there's no gear from
us we're getting the shitty training
sites like it was just a hot mess
we were [__] up in a lot of regards we
didn't know how to like plan and do
Mission prep like they were doing um why
is that like why like do you know why so
there's a thing called Stander operating
procedure but it is truly not it's
really more or less for per Battalion
and so the Third Battalion that I came
from it was really focused on uh their
main mission at the time was foreign
internal defense so they would do these
like training joint certification
exercise training events like all around
the world basically not Africa or not
Iraq not Afghanistan where our our
California Battalion was mainly focused
in
Afghanistan so they're doing a
completely different training that
theater requires a completely different
Mission planning not only for your
internal training but like how you
submit your concept of operations to
higher headquarters than Africa Africa
I'm like submitting [__] to like
embassies and yeah a person in Germany
like it's just just different so we
didn't know we didn't know once we found
out we came back for the final training
and like my team like smoked everybody
like you know we had the best everything
the best compos you're the best just
they were just top dogs and you know I
realized that you know you can turn you
can take any dull shoe and make it shine
but you have to put effort into it and
you have to like hey man we're going to
do this like you have to like bring
people up with you and that's one thing
I I noticed throughout my career is like
there's not a lot of empowerment a lot
of people don't Empower people it's like
I have to do all these things I have to
do all these things and uh there's
things that only you can do but there's
other things that other people can do
and as a leader one of the hardest
things is taking a step back and doing
this thing called trust you know um it's
really it's really hard but that's how
you Mentor your subordinance is I
remember this one guy he was a new
sniper in my team I'm like I I'm like
hey I need you to go to the Armory grab
all these weapons I need you to go do X
Y and Z do you have any questions and
he's like no I'm like do you have any
questions he's like no he comes back
like an hour and a half later I'm like
you get all this [__] done he's like
what was I supposed like how do I do
this I'm like okay this is why we ask
questions like I'm not challenging you
I'm here to support you but I can't
support you if you're withholding from
me and you know that changed his whole
mind mindset and Outlook but that's just
not a common thing like no you're a
piece of [__] you know like it's very
doggy dog but which is which is fine too
I mean life is doggy dog doesn't mean
you have to live that life you can
choose to but you don't have to be that
and uh that's what I really thought the
beauty was the military cuz people like
how are you getting away with that I'm
like I just did it how did you get that
help I just asked they're like what I
have that opportunity to him like
everyone's got that opportunity bro
they're like what I didn't know this
thing and you know towards the end of my
career when everything started like
diving into like my my wellness and my
my mental health you know that's when I
took advantage of that like that type of
empowerment like spreading the gospel of
like yo you can get you can take care of
yourself you don't have to like be a
piece of [__] and like suffer and be in
pain all the time and so I'm just I know
to a lot of people especially a lot of
triggered emotional insecure people
they're like oh he's talking [__] about
the military no one I can do that if I
want to but two I learned so much and I
learn I learn I learn how to face like
some of my biggest fears and stepping up
and speaking out was probably some of
the hardest things I ever did in the
military uh and that was like asking for
help and support with myself and you
know being an advocate for other people
to do that because that's not a not a
common thing I mean there's a war side
and there's a human side of that type of
job and it's just it's just it's crazy
where you where you can end up at if if
you choose to and none of it was planned
for me I always visioned myself being
like the top dog I always visioned
myself you know I told myself every day
I'm like dude you're be you're the
biggest strongest [__] in this
unit you're going to be [__] in
charge you're the baddest [__]
out there like why would I tell myself
any other diff I'm in a job that could
take my life you know if I'm in a job
that if I'm not bringing my aame I can
get someone killed why wouldn't I hype
myself up um but I realized a lot of
guys in the job they just they don't do
that a lot of guys that are really great
but they're like kind of linear they're
great at the Hard scary traumatic [__]
but they're not good with like their
social life you know communicating with
getting help or themselves and you know
that's really kind of like where I
flourished my myself into in my career
and then you know as a civilian now like
being a voice for the voices they have
the voice they just don't want to tap
into it because like if I do what's
going to happen to me you know and um I
think that falls in place like a lot of
people the whole like what if the
paralysis bio analysis type of thing and
straight up fa in your fears you got to
admit you're afraid I mean it's like
that first step right and and and it's
like making any kind of change you're
[__] stripping [__] off and there's
nothing there you got to fill it with
good stuff right I mean you got to
figure out something to fill with I I
just the way that you put it like doers
and speakers I've never really like
heard it heard that before and that that
makes like a [__] ton of [__] sense
to me I think doers always respect doers
and um I don't know if speakers respect
I don't know what speakers respect you
know like I I I I don't know um you know
aside from your own can you give me like
an example when I ask you like what is
the best example of like combat
leadership or military leadership or
something that you've seen like a
decisionmaking or like really being
there for somebody else uh what's the
first thing that pops into your
head I have a lot of examples I feel
like no I'm trying to put words to it
that's a good question that's a really
good question or just like some like
some person some person that you look at
that like had a huge effect on you
something that you saw them did no
matter how big or small how minor or
major in theater or not not like in
combat or not like just something you're
like [__] yeah like I'll follow him
anywhere or like I I I believe in that
like what what's that
quality willing to [__] throw it all
away for someone else there's ways to do
business
there's a way and there's the
way a way sometimes drills results the
way gets sh done but most people aren't
willing to do the way and I've a lot of
my leaders growing up they were the way
um I mean [__] man I I I [__] up so
many times in the military but I'm like
oh I saw really great leadership um but
to me like the best synopsis of like
like combat leader War leader just a
leader in general is literally someone
who is [__] selfless and like let's
makes it about the boys and that's not
an easy thing to do like to truly make
it about them and like make sure they're
taking care of um going above and beyond
like taking it to the face how many
times it takes just to get them with
they need and um I had a lot of examples
uh like that that I got to witness it
takes trust it takes trust um for
someone to like let go of their power
and to empower others with it that's
like not an easy thing to do and I think
how that's able to happen is you like
see it you see who like really cares but
who just needs that that help and that
leader is anybody that's what I try to
tell people leader is you don't need
combat you don't need military for this
[__] a leader is someone who steps up
when called upon to step up that's what
a [__] leader is and I've seen
leaders happen in all forms whether a
leadership position or not just someone
decided to do something [__]
different that altered the course of
someone's life or altered the the
outcome of of a situation that was
taking place and I don't really know if
I can give you like one
specific but it's a choice leadership is
a choice and literally anyone is capable
of being a leader um so are you prepared
are you prepared to face the
consequences of being one sometimes that
means responsibility sometimes that
means [__] punishment sometimes that
means banishment sometimes it means
being an outcast sometimes that means
being that [__] guy you know but why
else are we doing this we say we're
about Brotherhood and Sisterhood but you
know are we really about that and the
times I've seen leadership
happen I don't know it's just it was
just there just like you and your
friends you're really close friend
you're just like you do that that
[__] nod with your eyes and your soul
just connected and that's that's that's
all you need sometimes just like I see
you and for you when you again when you
were sort of face with some of the
[__] created it's like that look
that nod that that that that just
understanding without saying a [__]
thing that we're in this together and
then I'll follow you I'm G be right by
your side no matter what that's what
carries you forward yeah I mean I think
if if dudes dudes know they can trust
you they'll [__] go they'll go to
hell for you um I had guys defend me I
was under I had this crazy investigation
I was under for like two and a half
years and I had guys defend me all the
way to the end you know they they saw it
through I also had guys that [__]
rolled and made false accusations and
allegations the entire time as well uh
but they weren't my boys so there was
definitely a
um a common what's that like being under
investigation like your [__] family
calling you up telling you they [__]
hate you and that if any it's true they
just can't talk to you uh I put half
these off it was in regards with an
officer I was anistic
guy and I put I put the first three
courses first three pipelines through
marock
training and so I train a lot of
officers a lot of n of guys and these
guys that like I [__] mentored and
led and worked for and then they they
became my bosses and I supported and I
did what they asked and executed just
[__] turned their backs on me how so
wouldn't talk to me I'm like dude you
believe that [__] like I don't know man
I just because of this investigation
yeah because this investigation uh
because it was against an inlisted guy
and an officer which is a very like
[__] taboo thing you know it's like
the most like oh my God type of
environment and it was hard you know I
was removed from my team during this
investigation uh to let it cool off I'm
like why the [__] am I missing out like
why am I getting punished for this like
I I just had like like charges and
rights for that to me like that's it
like nothing else is crazy uh there's
like no proof none of this evidence type
of stuff happening but it's like it's a
reoccurring thing because this other guy
in question like he just wasn't
satisfied with the outcome so he kept on
bringing it up again and look how I look
dude I worked in a in a good old boy
organization where you got to look like
a little poster boy and that wasn't me
and I was a threat I had the rank I had
the experience the people knew I wasn't
a [__] and so like I wasn't going to
roll over and just
accept being like fisted by like lies
and deception yeah can you tell me what
the guy ACC you of or you can't if you
don't want to no I mean I'd rather not
it's like it's just cuz it's irrelevant
I'm like way past that aspect but that
the it's and like the guy and I like
we're like we're cool now yeah there's a
lot of and that was a great learning
thing for me I hated this guy for like
six years like how did you get through
that so six years later I'm now this
guy's [__] boss so he's still an
officer he's just got more rank I'm in
list guy I just had more rank uh but
he's he's manag he falls under Section
that I manage now and and the commander
at the time he's like I had to get some
paperwork signed by this dude and I'm
like I was being a passive [__] I was
like just going to put on his [__]
desk and like email him like Hey sign
this [__] and bring it back to [__]
so and so and so I went out grabb the
paperwor being a passive [__] walking
out with my intent to do exactly what I
just told you and I run right into this
[__] guy and we just like death stare
each other like I'm beating him to death
in my mind and I'm he's beating me to
Death In His too like he hated me just
as much right cuz it caused grief um you
know cuz this whole time and they they
do military does a thing called a well
most people do thing called a case study
and I was a case study in marso like
they gave me a different name but they
describe me to the tea and the situation
to a te and I'm being briefed in front
of all the [__] marlock like how
would you act if you were in this
situation and what's the right thing and
wrong thing to do and I'm in this like
leadership circle with some officer who
I put through [__] school reading me
the thing looking at me I'm like [__]
you know it's about me and he's like uh
well what would you do I'm like
I'm like do you think I have the best
attitude [__] no bro like my name is
being smeared I'm on the wall at the
probably not anymore but I was on the
walls like the history of our
organization and just getting [__]
blasted everywhere man
like like I'm a piece of [__] like like
I haven't sacrificed more than just my
[__] soul for this place and so I had
all that hate for this guy yeah but so I
run into him G him a sheet of paper and
then I take a step back cuz I'm a
[__] lead leader I can't I can't be
acting like that I had the hate but I I
can't be acting like this so what do you
do so I started to like catch when I'm
like how he was treating his Marines and
like how he was like taking care of them
I'm like [__] man this guy's been doing
a lot of work I went to sub his training
events I'm like man this he's not the
same [__] guy anymore and uh I I was
telling my boss I'm like hey dude like I
I can't hate this [__] I don't want to
hate this guy anymore man he's like yeah
good he doesn't want to hate you either
I think you guys should like make up so
like sure as [__] dude like we apologize
to each other
it was like this weight off my chest
dude six and a half [__] years dude
like if he were he was burning on the
side of the road I would just watch him
I'd probably like siphon gas out of my
[__] truck yeah like and put it on
him like I had so much discontent of not
just him but really what the whole
environment he was just kind of like the
this the the the nucleus behind it all
yeah uh but that whole environment T it
taught me so
much I was literally when we apologize
to each other it it was literally like
something we had did like four five six
years ago [__] yeah and I had I'm asking
myself like how much did that affect me
in in other things yeah you know like
how many more times have we go around
and people are like mumbling oh hey
that's so and so hey that's so and so
talking about him and I like watch out
for them because it was a thing I I was
plagued with for years um I remember
when I took over a company I'm so the
youngest guy that's in this this certain
Rank and I'm the youngest guy to take
over Special Operations company and one
of the first things out of my boss mouth
my Leader's mouth was uh hey you better
not pull that [__] you pull that other
officer I'm like you know I was
acquitted right you know like nothing
[__] happened all we know is macho
and the way it was it's just it's just
the stigma so like even though like I'm
I'm crushing it I'm [__] I'm crushing
it I'm empow my team my people are
crushing it like everyone's crushing it
around me this is the residual effects
of like a toxic work environment right
that you just couldn't escape I I had
the stigma for years of like the guy
that hated officers or disrespected
officers and you know I had some
allegations were like disrespecting
commission officer disobeying direct
orders like a bunch of like [__] that
can get you your PP slapped and a bunch
of other really crazy things that get
you really in trouble but it wasn't
disrespectful I just wasn't a [__] yeah
and most people expect I've seen so many
tough guys that are just they're just
[__] yeah you know when it comes to
like truly fighting for themselves not
their friends they're not [__] for
that right but for themselves I remember
one particular time we were our we were
doing jump our jump paay so we get paid
every month to jump to be uh free
followers or static line jumpers and you
have to maintain a certain amount of
jumps a quarter to maintain your
currency and your pay and they did this
huge audit at this point in time like
our commander at the schoolhouse was
like no no one can jump because the
focus was on these [__] students it
was like a big deal um and we're like
what the [__] they're like hey we're
going to take we're going to put in
waivers for your jump stuff fast forward
a few months turns out that wasn't the
case so now we're getting dock like
thousands of dollars a pay I'm in the
military bro I ain't getting paid like
all that and B of potato chips right and
my quality of life directly is affected
by this and they're like some guys just
accepted it I'm like [__] that so we
have this thing called request Mass so
basically I can go up my entire train of
command all the way to my Commanding
General and be like I don't agree with
this outcome I'm going to fight for it
and I I went to my boss's office one day
I'm like hey I want to request mask
they're like for what I'm like my jump
pay was
$1,700 I'm like dude listen I would have
requested mask for a [__] penny there
you go it's the principal and uh because
they just told us to they accept it and
some guys did some guys didn't fight it
I'm like pushover dude I like print out
my I print out my calendar I print out
all my [__] all my emails all this stuff
and I went all the way to the [__]
General through my chain of command I
get to the general now I learned this is
also a great lesson I learned that
General doesn't really have that much
power when it comes to your money they
can dock your pay but they can't say hey
you know what pay them back uh the Gman
owns your money uh Kansas City owns your
money and so um the general endorsed my
docket got pissed at my other lower
ranking officer and uh he's like I can't
guarantee you anything I still they
still took my pay the general endorsed
my [__] but Kansas City said [__] eat
a dick uh but it was just like I why
would I just accept it yeah you know and
but that's kind of like my alic on a lot
of it dude because like people use it's
fear tactics is a big thing in that
organization fear tax is a big thing in
civilian life oh don't be an
entrepreneur you're gonna fail don't
don't go for your don't go for your
dreams and quit your day job you're
going to suffer like all the everything
is fear fear fear fear fear and if fear
is the thing that keeps you from vesting
yourself then apply that to anything in
your life and do you want that outcome I
did not um you know but fast forwarding
a bit like you know letting learning
from this dude and uh maturing a lot I
was also falling apart mentally and
cognitively so I was opening up a lot
more uh at this time too in my life I
was very desperate for help I'm I'm
asking for help a lot uh I'm working a
super low speeed job uh where I'm
afforded this opportunity to take care
of myself and start this whole thing and
so it was like part of this healing [__]
I I knew at this time I was I was going
to be getting out of the Marine Corps I
didn't know how or
when but I could not leave with this
baggage
um cuz I know what it was doing to me
already like my wife knew about it you
know like that's bad and so being able
to heal and and and just like
acknowledge this dude's growth was he
still a g I don't know that ain't for me
to decide anymore but he grew so much at
the time but mostly so did I and for us
to be techn knowledge other as men and
be like [__] stupid how dumb was that
uh but that's that's that's leadership
that's learning you know you're you
don't learn by having a
perfect path for sure and and that like
just the power of just [__] forgiving
somebody you know cuz you're just
carrying around that [__] that that
toxicity you just like let it [__]
fester in you and you just keep on
letting it build and build and build and
grow and like you let it exist and it's
like there's such power and just being
like hey man let's just [__] cut this
[__] out right yeah dude I don't need
that stress in my life yeah [__] no and
uh you know I've talked to a lot of
people you know sort of for the
transition into civilian life like
obviously it's not nothing that I could
ever begin to understand but like what
what what did that feel like and if you
could um if you could sort of like
classify it or put into words how would
you scared
you know my whole identity was my job uh
my vision for myself was only the
military and when it when it came to an
end um I didn't know anything like
there's massive support network in the
special oper Community where like hey
what are the five jobs you want to do
we'll make you resumés and help you get
interviews and I'm like I don't know I
just started making up [__] and none of
them sounded lucrative to me I was just
so I was a new person cuz I I was even
acting differently like I was getting I
was I sold my motorcycles cuz I was
falling off my motorcycles I was getting
lost going down the street at my house I
was getting [__] lost and like we
sold our house cuz now I'm on this
medical board and about to retire of the
military so we're like downsizing our
life and try to set ourselves up for the
for the future and so I'm like selling
my dream truck trucks selling my dream
motorcycles downsizing my dream housee
uh I'm getting lost in apartments I like
viewing them with people and I was just
so desperate uh I thought that that was
the Pinnacle of my life I thought that
that was uh what I was here to do and
that was it and I didn't know what phase
two
was and so I was happy to get out cuz
like I wanted to be free and it was a
[__] blessing I got I retired four
and a half years early
um and I'm I was truly grateful for the
opportunity but I also was really open
with myself too during at the end of my
medical board I tried to self-sabotage
it again and try to try out for the
selection that I finally had an
opportunity to go
to and um I go to the neurosurgeon I'm
like hey I'm going to pause this this
Medical Board I I have a chance to go to
the selection now I'm going to go do it
he's like okay we can pause
it this is a [__] leader you want
that example this is a leader he asked
me if you made it over there do you
think you'd be liability I was like [__]
and I thought about it for a second I'm
like
yes if he never asked me that [__]
question I would have lied to him lied
to myself like I did for decade and a
half what were you chasing like what
what why sign up it was something I
wanted I felt like it was the next
progression of growth uh I wanted to be
in an environment that like people were
held accountable where there was a
standard where your families are taken
care of and so I thought right you know
it's the whole like grass it's green on
the other side uh my friends over this
unit they're they're [__] constantly
busy some of not don't really have great
lives and um but I wanted to know if I
could do it you know I wanted to know
could I [__] could I be a person that
that organization you know would be able
to utilize could have be an asset and um
and I wanted to for years I put in for
probably like five years and because my
rank and marock was very new of the day
so like they weren't releasing guys uh
that often and this place only has so
many like Marine billets um and now they
took off the Marine Corps took off the
rank restriction and so it's like I was
like it's like the perfect storm is like
my opportunity to go
and but I'm glad that happened because
that [__] doctor asked me that
question because of this opportunity and
I'm like [__] that's like really really
got red myself like I am I would I am a
liability my attitude actually is [__] I
am way more [__] up than I think I am
I am a piece of [__] to my
wife I need help I don't know who I am I
don't know what I want to do with my
life I don't know where I'm going I'm
[__] lost I don't know anything um
and so really
like open up this like bag for me of
like vulnerability which I now like lean
into um because it sets me free it's
like I'm like I'm gonna [__] die like
you [__] judge me if you want to you
know I want to be happy so I'm going to
go do this you know like it's the number
one thing that has helped me like
transform my life and like at least get
to where I'm at today uh and where I'm
at today is I believe in myself I'm
still lost and scared but I I I'm a True
Believer that the path isn't supposed to
be clear it's you illuminate it with
each step and each new opportunity that
I get it's like opening up a new doorway
a new threshold I'm just having this
thing called faith and like tell myself
you're not supposed to know I just
turned 38 you're not supposed to [__]
know that's right just keep on going and
I want to quit every day every day I
want to like what's my plan what I want
a job so I know like what I need to do
every day like I these are things I
[__] battle and if I had a job I'd be
like G I would just like it's I had a
job for four months as a civilian I
worked in the Cannabis industry and it
was
great cuz I realized that I am not meant
for four walls you know like I'm not
meant for that uh I I'm here for so much
more and I don't know what that is
specifically yet but I do know that that
ain't for me yeah you know
so I don't know I just I love a chance
to like try to figure out how to be
human now figure out how to like keep on
like not impressing but like answering
those voice in my head of like be better
do this do that go for this this scares
me go [__] do that you know you want
this next opportunity but you're not
doing the opportunity that's right in
front of you like trying to like really
like understand how to be human and how
to be me and um it's crazy you know and
and uh H how do you feel like uh service
how do you feel like service plays into
that helping others like like like like
put putting it into others like does
that solidify choices for yourself yeah
love it yeah what do you love about
it it would be selfish of me if I went
through all these things in my life if I
got if I got to experience all these
things in my life and I didn't share
them with people um when I got out of
the military my wife and I live lived in
a conversion van for about three years
and I went to social media and I just
like pour my heart out like all the
crazy [__] I'm like going through how
I'm depressed I'm sad I'm lost what made
you want to do that I just felt called
to do it mhm
I don't know why um I Had No Agenda
behind
it uh my wife and I sold L of our [__]
where we could like live off my
disability so we live like way way way
like lowkey so I wasn't taking I had a
job I didn't have anything I wasn't
trying to make money um at this point in
my transition I'm like the money is the
devil it's evil and all these types of
things but like I was still hurt I I I
was going through this like victim phase
I felt very betrayed by my country I
hated the military I [__] hated
everything and it was a big W me victim
uh phase of Life which I'm glad I went
through it's pretty common
huh it might be really common but it's
not probably common to acknowledge that
um but I was like very toxic I I was
positive toxic I would you know like
talk [__] in my mind or to my wife about
like people I saw winning on social
media I'm like that guy's a piece of
[__] man [__] him he sucked why is he
doing this I could be doing that Tot but
like you know fast forward my in my
growth of life I'm like well damn but
they're doing it yeah and the only
reason how they're doing it is they just
decided to do it and I started to apply
that with my life later on but I didn't
I didn't know that then and I didn't
know anything about my emotions or my
feelings um yeah but getting out I I was
so lost I didn't know who Cody Alfred's
my name but it's not who I am and I was
on this like mission to like figure out
who the [__] I was or who who am I um
and so the van was like the best thing
ever it was horrible I I complained 99%
of the time I had gnarly social anxiety
I gnarly depression um but my wife is
such a a g and a trooper man she like
did all this you know for me she did all
these things to like help me find
healing in myself and we didn't know the
blueprint of the path it just it
unfolded I was I was you know I'll give
myself plenty of credit I was [__]
Brave to to cut away it's very common in
my job to get out and go back to a gun
to make [__] you money but like to go
die in a country for a war that's not
even about what you think it's about
like just all these other silly things
that I just didn't buy into anymore like
I felt so called I got this opportunity
to live I got four and a half years my
life back you know I have this
opportunity just like everyone has an
opportunity am I going to squander it am
I going to do something with it and I
just felt so called just to like keep on
exploring me who am I what makes me tick
what's my belief system you know what do
I want to really do you know what's my
passion I didn't know of these things so
social media was a big part of my growth
and my transformation uh just cuz I was
just sharing so when you asked your
about serving people like oh my God I
[__] feel that way too and then I
just found myself being like this like
247 Hotline in my DMs and um which was
super dope it really helped me out to
serve people to help people but then I
realized that it was draining my soul uh
which I didn't feel connected to in the
first place and I'm like [__] I can't
help these people cuz they're they're
just draining me I'm getting a lot of
these suicide talks and I I've been on
the phone with the cops like random
person messaged me like hey my friend is
death by cop scenario can you can you
talk to the officer I'm like what the f
like I don't even know these people
right and it's
just I felt like I I have to do this I
have to do this and I I got into a plant
medicine and uh psychedelics and I
realized I have to help myself before I
can help anybody I didn't see that at
first um how did that come into your
life so actually it was like 15 days
after I officially retired hred for the
Marine Corps uh I'm having to get
together I'm not having to get together
I'm I'm at a friends get together and uh
one of our mutual friends he's like oh
dude you ever done mushrooms like no but
I've always wanted to uh he's like
because when I was do my brain treatment
in Tampa before I retired they said like
you could see like someone on mushrooms
you can see like the how their brain
fires and like how it just all lights up
and like I was so desperate to I was
kind of [__] [__] you know I was
still studying my words I was not
cognitively confident I was
I literally lacked confidence I went
from this confident Alpha stigma Persona
to like dude I was afraid of my own
shadow dude I had the worst perception
of myself I had body dysmorphia I
realized for like [__] 15 years like
whole time in the Marine Corps uh like I
was just really just dog garbage
relationship with myself I hated me um I
hated me a lot and
so he he's like he gives me like it I it
turned out to be like six grams and uh
he he's like I'm like what do I how do I
do he's like bro just [__] here take
this much and like I'm like okay so my
wife and I we like we like Venture off
into like BLM land and I she was down
for it I'm like I'm [__] desperate
dude like I I need this in my life and
like I set up my chair and I unek
knowing to me I I start creating I write
down my intentions not expectations
right I just felt called to do these
things like this kind of structure and I
[__] blasted off on my very first
journey and
uh I came out of it like holy [__] all
knowing you know like this like God
facade and my depression my anxiety were
like instantly gone I was instantly
happy um and so I'm back in the van for
like 45 days life is good my wife is
like dealing with me way better now and
45 days comes around is you know and I'm
just back to being a piece of [__]
[__] toxic I'm negative and nothing
nothing's nothing's good enough for me
I'm just I don't want to do this anymore
I'm just being a
victim and I didn't realize that you
know when you get that white space when
you we call we call it white space uh in
the military like when you like hey our
white space is this the basically all
the terrain that you own when you get
that that freedom buffer zone you have
to do the work you know it gives you the
the opportunity to to invest into
yourself and I didn't know any of this
[__] I'm like becoming a psychonaut you
know uh by myself and on my own accord
really
and so like that's when I got into like
self-reflection and journaling and all
these things to really use the power of
the plant medicine to dissect why I'm
acting a certain way how am I feeling a
certain way um and dude I've been doing
plant medicine for like five years now
and ever since I've been out
and it's been an absolute Game Changer
there's so many stigmas around oh I
don't want to go crazy like you're
you're crazy to know that you're [__]
up and and to not want to do anything
different about it I'm not saying plant
medicine for everybody uh but how you
[__] know yeah yeah yeah you know how
do you know the water is cold you go dip
your toes in there and you see if it's
cold or not then you [__] jump in
head first and have you done it with
have you done it with have you been
guided or do you always do it on your
own like how I started off on my own and
um my very first guided never with never
with mushrooms my first ceremony uh with
a shaman was improve did iasa and changa
out there and then my my second um did
your wife do it with you no no
uh it was crazy too so I've been doing
shrooms now for like two years and I'm
at my friend's house in the mountains of
Tennessee and I just come out of this
this trip I got there and his friend
shows like hey you guys want any shrooms
I was is like the universe talking to me
I'm like yes I I tripped that night and
my whole trip I'm expecting like to like
be in the cosmos and [__] crazy no it
was like I had my shirt over my head the
entire time it was a super internal
reflective one and I came out of that
Journey with this message saying I'm
living a life without me and that I'm
ready for the next
level and I'm like telling we're all
around a campfire as I come back from
the creek and I tell my wife and my
friend his wife this [__] and they're
like you think I'm [__] crazy right
you talk about any of this [__] people
think you're crazy sure the next day at
10 oock my phone rings and my friend's
like uh he's like hey there's a opening
up to go to Peru to do iasa are you're
interested and I was like what the [__]
and I told my wife this she's like I'm
like oh I can't I was scared yeah now
the I was scared of taking that next
step for myself it was too freaky how it
all kind of worked out and of course I
did what scarcity mind does we don't
have the money right my wife said we
have the [__] money go do it your
wife said that yeah she's a badass dude
yeah God bless her uh she's helped me so
much with like that scarcity mindset um
oh we can't my's like yeah we can I'm
like I can't throw my trash over there
the Taco Bell dumped her she's like yeah
you can just [__] walk over there do
it I'm like but I'm good they in trouble
like those are battles that I had in the
van I was so
insecure and so wow yeah Peru was my
first experience and then I just did in
October of last November of last year
with uh the nonprofit called Vet
Solutions I did IBU gain and 5o DMT out
there and that
was that's after years of doing uh
mushrooms LSD DMT iasa chonga and then
um to be able to do IBO gain and and 5o
were they were the were the absolute
game changer for how
so
Ian imagine it's it's a slow worker once
it's in you it's working I had a
completely different reaction to
everyone else uh that was guided it's
not these weren't guided they were like
you're in like like a ceremonial room
type of stuff and like you know uh you
have like OBS like Watchers but like hey
here's your Doses and here's your little
Rattler and you're like shaken and once
you start to have the effects you like
put your blindfold on you go do what you
got to do and I went out there I was I
felt so called
to to
uh to let
go I don't know what it was I just I
felt like I couldn't cry for years I
couldn't I just felt this thing to like
just kill myself like just I have to let
there's something I have to like I
couldn't pinpoint what it was I'm like
oh I have childhood trauma I'm like well
[__] do I I have War trauma I'm like
[__] I don't really have think about war
but there's something holding me back
in uh doing the 5o
DMT you have to let go you're going to
let go one way or another and uh I've
I've done DMT a [__] ton of times before
that and that is a you got to let go on
DMT also especially when you break
through but it was nothing comparable to
the bufo to the to the toad and um I
felt this ball of trauma not a
particular trauma but I felt this ball
of trauma drama leave my body come out
my mouth as soon as it came out my mouth
I just started balling I literally felt
it come up through my [__] throat out
my mouth and I just started balling and
I and I said I'm [__] free and I I
literally [__] pulled off my mask and
I'm like I'm [__] free and I'm like
I'm like [__] I just started like
roaring dude and I've never I felt like
I've had a governor on myself for years
yeah you know that you're like scream
I'm be like you know like very very like
half ass and I felt free man I I I felt
what I what I what I call is like what
God is you know I felt this this this
sense of love and opportunity that's
always been there uh I just I needed
that assistance I needed that uh I
needed to experience what I had with me
the entire time and uh there was no
level of like processing on my own to to
get rid of this
trauma and yeah it was crazy I I'm a
firm believer in it people but I think
people like fall to psychedelics oh it's
going to change my life no you're going
to change your life it's only going to
show you what you can be it's only going
to show you the [__] way but you know
if I tell you how to become successful
you still have to do the work that's
right if I if I tell you how to how to
live a healthier life you still have to
do the work right and that's the hardest
[__] thing people like the work there
is no pill you can [__] trip all you
want to bro but it it ain't Chang in
your life you have to reprogram your
subconscious mind you have to do things
or you're still going to live in another
state of delusional like [__] days
where it's just a little bit better than
your it's a little upgrade from your
normal hell you call existence but if
you have any like inclination to want
more out of life your life that you're
like holy [__] I'm going to die one day
what do I want to do before I die holy
[__] I've always wanted to go here [__]
I should probably plan that yeah take
that step yeah because once you plan
that you're like oh [__] I need $220,000
for this trip how can I get
$20,000 you start start thinking
differently you start thinking you know
how I love helping people win like I'm
on this growth of winning you know
externally and uh but mainly internally
but it all starts with like that you
just pull that thread and like what's
the next step and I love being able to
take the experiences of psychedelics and
convey them to people because is not for
everybody not everybody wants to do that
so how do you how do you help them bring
break their their chains that are in
their mind you know you have to be able
to articulate in certain way so I really
feel I just feel called to be a
messenger in a multitude of ways but to
just
hey man you're not alone you know like
you don't need Ward to have [__]
depression you don't need what I've had
to have this like I feel the same way
for X Y andz reasons and so many people
feel like we choose we choose to Avatar
together but people think because we
might have the same skin color or hair
or we drive a car we go to work that
we're all the same and that
we're this is just how it is and that's
not we we choose to play this game
called life we choose to do these things
we're so much more than
the exterior that we we call our reality
dude there's there's so much power I I I
think honestly man for like for you to
say th th those things and to say the
things you say and and I think that for
you say you don't have to go to war to
have trauma I mean like but look man
like anybody like all those voices in
people's heads it says man shut up man
stop being a [__] [__] and suck the
[__] up it's like for you to say that
after what you've been through and you
know what the [__] you've been through
that's why you've been able to step up
to leadership that's why you've been
able to stand up to the system when the
system was bullshitting you that's why
you you know what the [__] you've done
and you say hey look man I'm afraid
you've ad you admit that I I was acting
like [__] I was treating my wife like
[__] like for you to do that has such
[__] immense power because then
everybody else in their life be like
well [__] if he can do it I can [__]
do it and I'm just wondering like
specifically like what has been your
experience whether it's in like you know
the team's Community or whether it's in
like the veterans community period or
just in general like with depression
with suicide with people getting kind of
swallowed swallowed alive with this
stuff and and and and where do you think
this plant medicine can really step in
and and and be
effective yeah I mean depression is
definitely real once I realize what
stress and depression looks like
physically I can like see it in people's
face a mile away [__] puffy rosy red
cheeks you know [__] shallow
breathing uh easily triggered uh I can't
be in Walmart you know I mean I want to
go to Walmart first but like you know I
can't be in these like large social
settings um and my interaction with it
is like they don't [__] feel seen and
they try to still mask it you know I I
just lost a friend of mine um he's an
army vet he just killed himself the day
before Mother's Day sry and uh he had
plans to come see me he's like hey man
I'm come see you maybe we go do some of
that type of stuff
um and I talked to his wife and she was
telling me that uh they like set out
sausage he was going to cook sausage in
the morning uh it his mother's
day and he he said I'll be right back
and he didn't come back in a timy manner
and so she she called his phone and she
heard it ring and he's like this [__]
dude's like avoiding me so she went
outside the garage and she saw that he
hung himself and um I'm just
like so when it comes to depression and
suicide and all these things I have to
remind myself that like you know
everyone you only know the level of Hell
based on someone's willingness to open
up and expose it and even when they know
they're in a safe place to do so they
still don't um I I can't tell you how
many friends uh have killed
themselves um my my best friend killed
himself last year this time uh same
thing he's like hey I'm gonna come see
you in like two weeks we're going to
talk about business starting another
business together
and he he [__] kills himself um he
was battling depression he was battling
all all sorts of things and he was
definitely into plant medicine so I'm
convinced that people are going to do
what the [__] they want to
do and as much as I'd say I'd like to
stop suicide you're never going to uh
this guy my my friend that just killed
himself uh a couple weeks ago the past
year of his life has been the best year
of his life from being out the
military
uh I he was in actually my coaching
group I I I paid him he was an employee
like he was just like I saw so much
value in this guy like I brought him in
underneath the curtain you know and like
under my wing and um I I believed in
this dude and the way he treated his
family changed you know us working
together his whole life [__]
transformed and he still killed
himself and so I don't know why people
people do that I like the thing plant
medicine can help people but then the
day like the plant medicine reveals what
you have to do and it could be it's just
that one next thing and you know looking
back five years ago when I started this
journey for myself to heal my soul and
to find out who I
am if you had told me I had to do five
[__] years of this [__] to get to
where I'm at today I probably [__]
dead but we don't see the power of like
what time is when we're suffering we we
we want it fixed now but when we look at
um when we look at the Journey the
journey it is the way you know you're
supposed to suffer bro you're supposed
to really [__] question and doubt
yourself because that's when you find
all the good answers but I'm convinced
that as as much as I think my friends
are strong they're something [__]
strong in them I don't think they're
[__] weak I think they're [__]
stupid um and I I'm I'm brutally blunt
with that message because there's too
many [__] that think suicide is
their gateway to their [__] problem s
there's not people saying you're a
[__] idiot if you think that's the
only option you have you're a selfish
[__] my wife Lally tells me I think
about it a lot
dude I'm lost every [__] day of my
life that I
live and my wife tell she told me this
like after this guy killed himself she's
like if you kill yourself I will make
sure your son knows that you're a
[__] coward and I'm like
[__] and uh
so I don't know why these [__] dudes
and chicks do it I I think I believe in
I believe in predicted programming I
believe in I believe in all sorts of
programming uh they tell it to you on
every [__] movie with a veteran you
have to be suicidal uh you have to be
violent you have to be the
stigma uh I mean that's the culture
we've
built um plant medicine can't save you
at the end of the day you have to save
yourself no Sky Daddy no [__] plant
is going to really save you
that's the power you have and that
should encourage you enough to [__]
make it happen I you know I I see all
these stories of of men and women that
are literally like [__] in a CL me
bag they got no [__] limbs they're
they're breathing on a [__] straw you
know but they're like they're doing it
[__] yeah every [__] day they're
probably not in La La landay in their in
their minds they're probably suffering
but they're doing it every day Fu and
that's what a [__] leader is a leader
does the [__] that nobody wants to do a
leader does a [__] that's hard and it's
scary you know my my friend killed
himself last year his wife told me that
oh he thought he was having dementia and
didn't want to be burdened and I
probably butchered that a little bit but
I'm like I would have wiped that [__]
dude's ass until the day he died that's
what a [__] friend is and when you
think that you know people like I've
gone through so much you didn't go
through it to to be selfish and kill
yourself that is someone else's
salvation if you just open your [__]
mouth and share your journey um but
there's so many selfish [__] people
in this life and they take this pain and
this trauma and they haven't figured fig
out how to transform it like I'm an
alchemist I've turned my shitty ass
[__] metal tar tarnished shrapnel
into [__] gold and everyone has the
same power everyone has that ability but
they haven't tapped into that that way
of living yet because they don't believe
in themselves they're scared it's hard
it's unknown where do I start [__] you
start by starting you start by saying
you don't know where you're at and
that's how you start congratulations
you're on your journey amen then you
start by like oh [__] these are the
things I do that bring me to the same
space maybe I don't do those things so
it but it's not easy it's not supposed
to be easy and to me that's the gift of
life like I'm not here to [__] work a
job invest in a 401k not buy my dream
car because I'm being a good Steward of
my money become 7 years old decle as
[__] and then I die that sounds like a
boring ass way to go that just that
sounds horrible but that's an American
that's the program we have here not be
your best self you want to be [__]
happy what makes you think you can't be
happy I saw I saw I remember my second
deployment I'm in Iraq I ran into this
family from Uganda it was a mother and
like three [__] kids and they were
washing clothes in like dirty muddy
water smiling meanwhile but in the for
in the background there's like a [__]
tank blowing up a building there's the
spreaded gunfire happening and um one of
the French bers we had she said she was
just happy that she wasn't getting
[__] raped it's all perspective and
one thing I love about um I'm a huge LSD
fan and what I love most about LSD is
that it shows me the different
dimensions my whole life is a is a
[__] analog TV I can flip to this one
this Channel and be happy today I can
flip to this channel I can be sad I can
flip to this channel be a [__] I can
flip I can flip to any channel and have
a different reality and I can do that
right now you feel like you have control
over the over the the flipping I've seen
it yeah what's the difference you ever
gone out side like man it's going to be
a shitty day it's [__] rainy outside
and then the Sun comes out like 5
minutes later you're like woohoo let's
go to the beach what happened your
perspective happened that's what
happened yeah you went from being having
the worst day of your life because of
[__] sun and then five minutes later
your whole outlook on everything
changed that's how powerful you are the
sun didn't change you you decided to
change yourself you're like uh-huh now
I'm happy because you're Associated to
this and all these psychedelic Journeys
that I've been on and I've realized that
I really can change these stals dude if
I want to be [__] suicidal I'd be
dead as [__] if I really want to do it
I'd be [__]
gone but I want to live
more you if I wanted to be a [__]
when I don't agree with my wife and I
want to repeat the same thing I did for
years where I just pester her and buck
her I can be that I'm still that guy I
can still be that dude but I choose to
[__] be on a different dial because I
[__] with all these dials I know all
those realities exist right now and I
have that power to [__] become
whatever Channel I want to be
and I can literally step into any role
of that right now if I want to be pissed
you know when my friend killed himself
I'm
like I was sad I cried but I'm like [__]
dude I'm I'm not gonna I'm not going to
waste this this finite time that I have
crying
anymore yeah I'm [__] honor all these
[__] by living and not being a
[__] when I want to [__] check out
when I want to like you know throw in
the [__] towel cuz my life is harder
or or I'm up against the wall you know
like
it's easy to do that but it's easy to
change these channels people do it all
the time in their reality but they won't
apply it to their internal reality
because they think there's a disconnect
but this is all a projection of what we
have in here okay you know what I'm
saying and is it that easy to to have
that perception no that took me time it
took me an investment to like to get to
my and this is my world this is my
conclusion will a bear still eat me
absolutely can a car hit me on a highway
if I walk in the middle of the street
absolutely but can I have a good day
even if I having the worst day of my
[__] life absolutely how do I know
I've done it already so now I just have
to remember how to bring back that
feeling into my present moment and
realize that what I'm going through
right now is I I have to be going
through this to hit the next phase I I
worked with a few highend clients and
they have all the money they have
they're super successful they can
everything touch it turns to Gold they
can create anything and their common
theme is
fulfillment they're looking for
something bigger they're looking for
them MH and um I think half the world is
looking for them I think half the world
doesn't even see them like when I work
with people I'm like go go find the
nearest mirror and focus on your pupils
most people won't even do that like oh
that's just weird that tells me you're
disconnected from yourself and that's
not a bad thing but now you know that's
a that's a that's a step one if you want
to choose to can't take can't go on if
you don't do that first step yeah and
that's just one of Min steps right but
like how can you really acknowledge your
internal dialogue if you don't even
acknowledge yourself and I mean for
years dude I avoided me I hated who the
[__] I was like I even when I was like
255 and jacked I thought I was like Anor
rexic as [__] like I'm I'm still kind of
getting over like the body dysmorphia um
but that was like two decades worth of
[__] right like I hated my internal
dialogue was not congruent with like my
outside world my outside world I was
great my inside world was absolute like
hell I hate do you know like do you have
any idea like where that was coming from
or does it not matter I never felt it
was trauma dude I never felt valued and
appreciated you know a lot of it came
from the military like there was no adab
booys in the military I walk into rooms
the military you know being the senior
guy with all the chest candy uh knowing
that I'm a badass not because of what
I'm wearing but just like I know inside
like I'm a badass like I was a badass
when I was in the boot camp you know
what I'm saying like it doesn't really
matter as on my chest I know my worth
and value but I walk into these rooms I
feel so inadequate I like I didn't
belong there because you're always
getting like this [__] mean mug like
you know like there's always sizing you
up on everything you're doing
and you know then I told you about like
my dad like I'm just I just wanted my
dad tell him tell me he loves
me uh like verbally saying it you know
and so I never felt like I never felt
valued I never felt like uh my sacrifice
was worthy of being acknowledged because
my environment never like let that it
never happened there um so that's when I
got out I really felt like that that
whole victim mindset I was telling you
about uh being like connected and woes
me you know which I'm glad it happened
it needed to yeah it needed to yeah look
man I appreciate how much time you're
giving us man I know it's it's it's
[__] long I guess my last question is
just like how how this just manifests in
in in in fatherhood and what fatherhood
does for you and and and and how you
approach
it so I have a seven-year-old son that
lives in Germany that I get to see for
the first time in 7even years wow um uh
in a couple months and I'm I'm really
excited I'm terrified but I'm really
excited
um I have a a a younger son he's 16
months
and when he was born I was like [__] I'm
a selfish person by trade when he was
born I'm like [__] I can't do what I
want to do now and I was just like
really like battling this like who am
I and like the first three 4 months of
his life I'm
like I didn't feel the shift I was like
thinking this magical shift is going to
be there and I'm like going to click for
me and like it's just I'm just magically
not going to be a piece of [__] anymore
and I'm just going to be the greatest
that
ever that did not happen that did not
happen it was probably like six months
old he looked at me and he like touched
my pinky and I [__]
melted and
uh I love both my sons I I hate more
than anything that I created a
statistic uh with my oldest son
something you hear about the military
like these [__] got kids all
over the place and no fault of anyone's
long life is life [__] happens but I
didn't want to be that guy and uh I know
what growing up and wanting my dad's
attention was like like it took me to be
an adult to work through a lot of [__]
to to reflect back on that but to like
put my oldest son in that type of
situation and and the craziest thing is
I I struggle still to this day
I don't even know how to conversation
with them we we speak different
languages um and so I'm really I'm
really excited to just like go out there
and like just go to war with it you know
just like I'm [__] here for this
let's do this um but with my youngest
son I have to watch myself I love on him
a lot not like
baby but I just I look at him and I just
like you're worth everything M you're
you you you're so pure
and I'm like [__] he he reminds me that
I'm going to die one day he's if you
ever never thought you were going to die
cuz you're [__] delusional your kid
is an actual life clock that's right and
um wow I look how I view my mom my dad
passed away years ago but I look how I
view my mom and yeah I'm a mama's boy my
mom and I did a lot of healing together
and my mom and I's relationship is like
super
legit uh but it wasn't always like that
I was I was a i traumatized my mom my
whole time in the Marine Corps I was a
[__]
um so it took getting out and a lot of a
lot of plant medicine a lot of lot of
healing and self-reflection to to menend
that relationship that's a lot of years
of programming that I did to
her and she you know she was programmed
to react a certain way and interact with
me and I just I'm like I look at her I'm
like [__] I love her so much I wonder if
my son's going to love me as much as I
love my mom I wonder if my son knows
that I love him and I'm just trying to
be better uh and so I look at him and
the whole fatherhood aspect about all
this is it's it's scary cuz I don't know
I don't know what I'm doing you know but
that's okay I have a lot of great men in
my life and I love when my when my son
is like when my friends come over I'm
like hey you want to hold my son like I
want my kid to be exposed and I met the
whole tribe thing I get it like I'm
about it it takes a village to do this
type of [__] I don't want to be the only
dude my kid knows I want him to be I
want him to see these these men because
20 years from now we're going to see my
son and he's going to be [__] 20
doing whatever the [__] he's do and
we're we're going to be able to
reminisce on this and we're going to be
able to impact the life you know and
that empowers my friends to get another
opportunity and it's just great and then
being a dad really reminds me like [__]
dude I got to take care of my health and
my wellness and um my last phase of
growth really for me that I identified
was the body that's that's action as
well as my physical body and so I've
been working with a coach uh her name is
Rebecca she's super legit uh for my
mobility and like my actual strength not
my ego strength my actual strength the
functionality strength and training and
uh get my [__] hormones checked you
know we both obviously know Sid and
cormed and uh just My overall Wellness
like what I'm eating how I'm sleeping
like I'm going to doing a brain
treatment facility again in two weeks
not like a month my TBI are like really
affect me again and um how did they
affect you it happened like a year and a
half ago it was like it was significant
like like switch I'm like oh [__] I'm
[__] like I went from like super Flow
State to very like rambly all over the
place like my ADHD is like very bad but
it's not even positive like super genius
way it's
like I don't I need help so like I
started hiring more people to like I
need help for the simplest dumbest [__]
um because if it's up to me like I'll
just [__] I'll ruin it like I I'll
make sure the ship sinks even though I
have a way to save it I just I can't get
it out out of here um I'm stuttering a
lot more coming up with words uh is
becoming quite difficult again
navigating um structure that is like the
most impossible thing for me timelines
is unheard of for me and so but it's
really it's really bad like I can't my
short-term memory is really bad like
it's it's cause a lot of issues in my
relationship um you can only tell people
so long hey my TV and then but it's like
really my [__] TB and um but I
believe in like investing in myself in
all these ways cuz I look at my son like
dude I don't want to be mush brain I
want to be part of this kid's life and I
can't I can only control what I can
control so I'm just trying to like
influence my my environment to the best
that I possibly can um but yeah I look
at my youngest son and I'm just like
dude I I love you so much and he's like
worth it and my wife and have this
conversation like dude we have to be
[__] jacked we have to be [__]
healthy we have to be [__] you rich we
have to be [__] like [__] you
independent like we have to do all these
types of things because if we don't how
are we going to tell him to go do that
and there's multiple realities you know
there's like in the military there's
play the game or there's [__] do the
job I did the job I didn't play the game
yeah as a civilian it's the same thing
you can like do what you're supposed to
do or you can like let's get creative
and figure out how we can earn our
income provide for a family spend more
time with their son and like that's what
we're doing now is like do as much work
as we can from home and on online so we
can like maximize time with our on our
Homestead and with their kid and we're
not going to send our kid to public
school like
why why if I don't want to do that right
that's all I need to know is because I
don't want to right right and um we
can't ever encourage him to like be his
best or show him a new way of life if
we're not creating one for herself so
it's been a been a good challenge and um
it's a it's a good proof in the pting
putting that self-work and the
investment and psychedelics have all
worked for me cuz like he'll lose his
[__] I'm just like chill [__] just
chill my wife she's like sometimes she
like lose her [__] she spends way more
time with him but I'm just like it's not
a big deal like we'll figure it out you
know yeah but before the that would not
have been me so he just reminds me to
like be better I just want to be better
mainly for myself but so he can benefit
um but yeah fatherhood's crazy right
dude that shit's real as [__] bro that
shit's real as [__] it's like every day
is one day less right and it's like we
all you know I love what you said that
human clock that's like so that's so
[__] true man and and uh and bro you
got anything you got anything else you
want to say or anything for
me I appreciate you dude I appreciate
you too man [__] I really appreciate you
man thanks for
uh you know i' I've said those things
before and I've never like I never
like I'm growing I can feel growing um
if I can just share about my service dog
real quick you said that yeah please um
so my I met
mun
2011 um this company calls Fallen they
were they were at the SHOT show in Vegas
and my friends went up to them kind of
fast forward and they're like hey Cody's
in a bed State I was during that
investigation um and they're like we
need to get Cody a dog and
uh went down to Jackson Hall Wyoming did
some training with other dogs and
they're like this is the dog for you I'm
like no she's a girl I don't need her I
want a manly dog I want like something
terrifying and yeah I I trained with all
of them and they were just not good for
me they were just two in the red I need
to like not that and so they brought
back mun she's a German Shepherd Belgium
now she like runs and jumps on this like
platform and like puts her head on my
lap and um 24 hours later I go home with
her and that dog save like physically
saved my life like numerous times and um
about
January she was uh I brought the dog
every with me at work she went to Dives
with me I took her to freef fall school
she [__] on the mat like it was a big
deal uh but like cuz she was trapped in
she got trapped inside and she wasn't
able to go outside but I I I was so
grateful because people like brought her
with me or people allowed her me to
bring her with me and um January her uh
her hip displasia really kicked in she
started going blind and really see now
just barking all night and I felt I
looked at her and I just felt so bad how
I'm I was a bad dog dog leader and how I
didn't take her out and walks every day
and I just all this regret my life and I
didn't think I was strong enough to like
to help her and take care of her
and I kept on putting it off since
January I'm like I'm I can't do this I'm
not strong enough for this she'll be
okay she'll be okay
um and um she just wasn't man she's in
[__] pain and my dog's she was
[__] Warrior she's Savage and um
that's the type of dog that just wanted
you to know that she loved so here I am
looking for love for my dad looking for
acknowledgement from other people and
and I had it the whole
time and I told myself like I have to I
have to do this like a big this is a big
like step for me
and you know letting go of my service
dog
was the hardest thing that I've done
that dog literally saved my life so many
times and
uh but it also the biggest growth spurt
in my life in my in my in my recent life
that I can really look back on I'm like
I'm I knew this is part of
it because I had to be a leader for her
you know I was I was so
selfish and I felt even worse that I was
she was suffering and I'm like oh she
can still kind of get around she's not
that bad
and but what that dog did to my life I
mean was is like
legendary and um but to take her to the
vet to schedule that appointment and to
take her there and to
you know I [__] bathe her and groomed
her her last day and it was a it was a
part of the process and another reality
that nothing lasts forever in this life
and I don't know I just I just wanted to
share that I really felt
that letting go of
her help me
grow um because holding on to her pain
and suffering I was holding on to a lot
of my insecurities and
my uh my remorses and my regrets in life
and I flash back my whole life with her
and like things I was doing things I was
going
through and then just to see those eyes
and
um just what a gift you know all these
all these things that we have in life
that are that are there for us to guide
us and it's right [__]
there
um to me that was like the most special
gift I've ever got the experience with
her what's her life
and what having
to I'm not say man up but having to like
step up and
like do the thing that I didn't want to
do be a [__] leader um it was it put
me in this like different state of uh
state of being that I haven't had in a
long time you know so like I'm just like
[__] it you got to just you got keep I'm
[__] going dude like this is part of
the journey you know um because when I
got immuned and I wasn't worried about
oh she's going to have to die one day
yeah no one thinks about that no and
then reality comes um but I'd be doing
her disservice if I threw it all away if
I didn't take all the good that she's
giv me yeah so um I just wanted to give
her a shout out man yeah man God bless
and and do you want to honor do you want
to tell me uh do you want to just tell
me is there like one special story about
her you said she's saved your life so
many is there anything just by by like
honoring her like something tell me
about how special she
was yeah uh when I first got her home
she didn't she literally laid on my
chest panting for like weeks at a time
um and I I call them and I I called the
people I got her from and they're really
spiritual people and they're like oh
yeah she's taking your demons from you
she's taking your pain from you and um I
feel like dude she she was just supposed
to be there and the one of the greatest
lessons she taught me and she did for me
was like I judged the [__] out of her
because I'm like I thought I in in a
state of like help and Des desperation I
thought I knew what was best for me but
the the owners of the company they they
knew exactly what dog I needed I'm like
I know better and I'm like how many
[__] times I doing that in my life
all these other things yeah and then
when you just let go and you let go your
[__] ego you let go all the stuff and
you're like dude she walks with me the
best she loves me for no other reason
than she loves me
it was just lesson after lesson after
left them she couldn't play fetch for
[__] she was an [__] she would go get
the ball and she would drop it like four
feet in front of you yeah dude I'm like
you [__] dick um but man just
thinking about all those opportunities
to that I would never have had if it
wasn't for her and her helping me heal
and honest and change stigma even like
the the mental health game in my
organization like why does that guy have
a dog like [__] you that's why [__]
yeah with [__] you man my life is
important and people were like yeah [__]
yeah [__] yeah and so the people who got
the head on they got it they understood
it the people who didn't get the head on
[__] them yeah you know and I'm just
like that's how badass my dog is dude I
just get to share time with her and I
just you talked about it earlier and I
just I just wanted
to
just give my love my my my Raven a
[__] shout out man [__] yeah man I'm
glad I'm really glad you did man I'm
really glad I'm GNA carry that man hey
man thank you for doing this
[Music]
bro